ok et c'est parti bonjour tout le monde
ouais nous sommes là pour la demi-finale
du junior speech à ce championnat entre
way i feel russia et moi ce sera un
match de trois heures et demie de blitz
et puis le bol et voilà que ça commence
déjà siciliani ouais j'avais essayé
d'arrêter mais les bruits
je crois que c'est l'ouverture principal
de l'irena est que lorsque tous les
chinois veillée incluant commencé de te
défendre 4,5 défense pétrole même si ce
n'est pas vraiment son style je crois
qu'ils veulent probablement internet
entre 4h et cécile hockey est ce que tu
penses que ça dépend de dos il
al'avantage dans le match qui jouirait
d'un style ou l'autre ou ça dépend de
comment les parties bon c'est difficile
à dire pays je ne connais pas très bien
ce qu'il ya des joueurs qui essaient
toujours de jeux joués 2 dans leur style
et d autres qui sont plus pragmatiques
qui sait le changer un peu d'accord au
score par exemple ok maintenant je vais
ajouter les caméras des deux joueurs
non je vais pas je les vois pas aller
voilà parfait
réussite hockey challenge ou exotiques
ouais le pian h qui avance la qui se
ruent sur le roi blanc oui ils ont
reculé ces trois ouais ouais ça j'ai vu
ça j'ai vu dans les ici s'ils viennent
fermer parce qu'on veut jouer c2 c3 pour
chasser le cavalier mais je comprends
bien tu investis beaucoup de temps pour
ça c'est comme un ce que tout le monde
serait ok il ya un joueur de qui jouait
toujours à cissé vient de fermer
chez nous à san francisco et je lui ai
vu du très très très souvent joué
cavalier des 1 c2 c3 et puis cavaliers
f2 pour aller al maleh le roi avec
lecavalier en train de prendre contrôle
au centre donc ce sens ouais donc en
premier lieu le cheval va sur ses trois
pour arrêter des cinq thés noirs
et puis quand il ya un cahier sur des
quatre ils changent de position pour
jouer ces trois et des 4,6 aussi les
noirs qui ont joué cavalier ses 6 7 et 4
et puis il retourne en c6 donc
maintenant on se dit qu'un traître doit
reprendre le 2 mai maintenant et un même
siège
il peut le faire ici alors ouais
c'est intéressant
ouais ouais sacrifice de qualité ça va
aujourd'hui c'est ces petits rouges a
dans sa danse à partie dans la ligue
turque qui a joué une sacrifice de
qualité pour croiser 2700 mai mais ici
c'est lui qui prend la qualité de wailly
dans la première partie c'est
impressionnant je lui connais depuis
leurs joueurs autour de 2500 elle a
progressé de 3 au début un jouet j'avais
un très bon score et aujourd'hui ça
arrive en france et déjà c'est très
difficile donc je sais pas si tout le
monde suit tout cette compétition mais
en bref c'est une compétition de 16
jeunes 16 joueurs de juniors de moins 20
ans et enfin le gagneur entrera dans le
dans le speech à ce championnat général
avec eux les nakamura et maxime vachier
lagrave et tout ça le meilleur du monde
et nous en sommes aux demi finales donc
il ya déjà eu une demi finale de passe
et c'était entre parra maqsoud loue
aussi de viron et jeff richmond
l'américain qui lui aussi vient de
croiser 2700 il ya ce mois là et c'était
déjà free qui a gagné ça donc le
vainqueur aujourd'hui joue aura en
finale contre jerry yang et puis le
vainqueur entre ces deux-là continuera
au championnat - sans limite d'âge
mais je pense que tous les quatre c'est
demi finalistes pourraient jouer dans le
dans le championnat a speech à ce sens
sans ce sens se faire détruire faisons
fi rosen ils sont déjà entre les
meilleurs 45 monde ouais ouais
et oui aussi évidemment salut bleus bon
ok si si le fouetter active je dirais
que les blancs sont en train de gagner
facilement donc peut-être si peu se
mettre sur h3 éventuellement faire
quelque chose sur f5 ce serait assez
pour pour les blancs sinon c'est
compliqué je crois qu'ici cherche deux
coups assez directe common et g5 rentrée
le 6 oui l'autre idée c'est de jouer
vite et forcer et puis c'est le nom des
six donc ici menace cavaillès 6 donc si
les noirs ne peut pas retourner la tour
doivent jouer tour j'ai cet échec et
puis échec sur 17 anglais les blancs ont
regagné leur leurs qualités déjà et avec
pont de pian de plus ces attaques qui
continuera donc la position devient
facile pour les blancs
ce plan de 1,54 n'a rien apporté un nom
et c'est impressionnant avec quelle
facilité il y avait la qualité du tout
réfléchi et là tout de suite 5 après
cavaillé des quatre mois le voilà
cavaillé des 4 et puis il a joué
cavalier prend des quatre en une seconde
c'est marc ela une seconde vie 3 donc
voila c'était pas un calcul
oui il a juste décidé que le plein de
compensations matérielles sont
maintenant vides donc maintenant pour
convertir moi j'aimerais jouer h4 et
touré set mais il a déjà fait quelque
chose d'autre à mes jeux voici le tour
va on et h7
il a aussi fou 4 donc la tour commence à
perdre les cases nécessaire oui oui oui
maintenant c'est l'embouteillage chez
les noirs mais l'affairé est loin de
nous aucun contre contre je vois le
menton et abandonnent parce que le pion
à chf a juste continuer ok je dois
toujours fermer la partie d'avant hockey
compris bon firouz j'aille jouent pas
très souvent eu quatre avec les blancs
qui passent pas comme avec les blancs
les partis il ya de tout du tout ok donc
on peut s'attendre à une variété
peut-être aujourd'hui sûrement on va
voir moi jai vue pas très souvent mais
mais quelquefois j'ai vu au
la production nous envoie des infos sur
allez reza firouz jala il vient d'avoir
16 ans en juin et côté maintenant de
2700 deux numéros 3 juniors du monde
après oui son adversaire d'aujourd'hui
et jeff richardson adversaires
potentiels de de la finale il dit que sa
force c'est la souris et faiblesses et
qui qu'il devient frustré si les choses
ne vont pas dans sa direction
ça c'est tout selon lui même les jeunes
attendent expériences sont tellement
bien ouais je pense aussi que c'est un
joueur comme hyper confiant et ton que
souvent les joueurs qui attendent
beaucoup de même quand quelque chose ne
va pas et deviennent très très frustré
ou fâchés donc par exemple si c'est un
peu le cas avec kasparov faut qu'arsène
où ces types là c'est cette personnalité
ou même si on gagne si on n'a pas joué
de la meilleure façon on attendait mieux
de soi même on gagne le tournoi mais on
dit oh j'aurais dû faire plus 6 au lieu
de + 5 des trucs comme ça je pense qu'il
est un peu comme ça donc quand il gagne
il n'est pas surpris mais quand ça va
pas il comprend pas exactement pourquoi
ça marche pas pourquoi il aurait pu
faire des erreurs
tu te rappelles quand carson avait joué
kasparov pour la première fois étant
enfant de peut-être 12 ans ou quelque
chose il a choqué le monde avec une
partie nulle mais lui
il pensait plus sur la partie qui avait
perdu il a dit j'ai joué comme un enfant
lorsqu'il était en fin de compte un
enfant week-end on l'a éliminée parce
que on veut plus de français en ligne
rincer la conspiration de la cia comme
vous dites mais comment vous le savez ça
déjà nyoni bas comment êtes vous au
courant des ja et puis qu'est-ce que why
i doit faire ici pour garder ses deux
pions et orgue y en a deux en l'air et
sir français ouais je suis toujours
content parce que les accents je suis
très fier ouais c'est vrai t'as pas
l'accent allemand
en réalité quand j'ai étudié aux états
unis un tiers des gens pensaient que je
suis français quand je parlais anglais
et te tiens mais c'est que je suis allé
et pour chacun qui pensaient que je suis
français je suis content on a aussi
changé max ou de louer chiant pour willy
et fille revient c'est chiant qui a
gagné l'autre partie et legagneur
aujourd'hui je vous raconterai contre
lui bon je sais pas si oui a réussi à
garder ses pions je voyais pas quand il
le ferait et pour l'instant il n'a pas
encore fait difficile à dire si c'est
vraiment parce que la structure est
mauvaise le pion se trouvait assez
faible les développeurs sont les noirs
qui sont plus confiants temps déjà mais
pourquoi pas prendre sur à 8 ici
je peux le faire mais après y aura dans
le cinq et noir avec ses 3 2 1
c'est probablement un set contre je
gagne un autre pion one ok huawei jeu
moi je jouerai peut-être eu 3 je
donnerai le penser c'est vrai et noir
ont un pion et la reine contre d'huile
sur trois déjà quand le poteau
donc il ne le fait pas mais c'est quoi
son plan sur deux autour des 8 tam e3
d'un me 3 et essayer de garder son pion
extra pour le moment à et maintenant il
faut rendre d'abord à parce que si tu
joues tout reste il prend en 1/8 et un
des quatre il reprend avec le pion ou ce
serait plus pop au mieux ah oui donc il
joue avec l'autre tour pour mettre les
tours ont évité ces 8 % contre je à mon
avis du noir le tour de huit tomes 3 et
la dame blanche de fond tout donc
thompson pour enlever le la meilleure
pièce
et puis pas revenir sur d2 avec un
accent qui joue avec ce pour moi le
moment que je vois que c'est le tour en
a un qui reste là pour moi c'est clair
que les blancs ne peuvent pas avoir les
avantages avec un tour sur avec la
tension est un
c'est que dit quand il pense que tu es
français ça veut dire que qui pensent
que tu parles mal mais qui préfère ça
que qui pensent que tu parles mal mais
de façon allemand mais c'est sain et
quand je suis en france pour un choix de
mots ne peut pas être que d'un français
donc les gens pensent que je suis
français parce qu'elle ne voit pas
l'accent mais je dois être quelqu'un de
la campagne 7
à oui comme je vois tu viens des ch'tis
[Musique]
en fait
bon il a joué dans ces cinq comme tu as
dit super vite et fit rouge a été obligé
de mettre sa dame en afgha très vite et
pour le moment cette simplification
c'est un peu comme le bingo c'est le cas
fameux mais parfois si on a meilleure
structure même champion c'est bon
d'aller en finale et ses jours avec le
pion de plus qu'il ait dit lorsque moi
je vois toujours la dame comme comme une
pièce tu de défense très importante
puisque la dame peut protéger beaucoup
attaquer beaucoup
donc si on enlève la dame tous les
bienfaits bleus deviennent vraiment
faibles
ok donc on te demande si tu attends des
chiens au final champ contre max zhu
xian combler ce qu'est ce que tu penses
de ce serait juste
ce jour là mais c'est vrai moi c'est
vrai que fit rouge a déjà joué
aujourd'hui dans un autre tournoi dont
il pourrait être un peu fatigué dans ce
match c'est possible mais oui joue aussi
dans la ligue en chine qui est en fait
plus dur que la ligue en turquie il a
perdu une partie contre dingli rennes
hier je sais pas ce qu'il a fait
aujourd'hui mais mais tous les deux sens
sont en train de jouer des tournois cet
intermédiaire ok mais c'est possible
mais baffie rouge à sa partie
aujourd'hui je les ai pas trouvés si si
l'on vous si difficile que ça son
adversaire avait joué une grande salle
d'ajouer fou hcc pris un tour sur ses
seins et puis puis rouge a mis sa sont
fous qui était déjà sur des 4 puis l'ami
saddam sur l'a 6 et 7 et mat
je pense que c'est plutôt inspirant que
fatigant d'avoir une partie où on gagne
mais surtout quand tu joues bien tu as
l'impression que tout fonctionne tu en
es ce que les noirs vont prendre le pion
c4 oui et très bien très bientôt
ici à moins que dame 5 soit encore plus
fort il s'incline 17 mai donc ça marche
pour les droits
je crois que notre but c'est simple
comme les postes au mais oui il a vu un
feu rouge ou un autre truc je crois que
clara titre ça c'est un côté bleu et
maintenant il n'a pas d'autres chocs
blanche est terrible ouais mais les
noirs aussi blanc les blancs peuvent
prendre ici sur le site puis défendre
sur f2 donc ils vont perdre le pion c4
aussi donc ou wii et et noir reste
qu'une tour à tour actif donc ces
gagnants tu pense oui oui c'est gagnant
une seconde pour perugia il était à sa
limite en position et en temps et a déjà
l'air un peu frustré bien sûr parce que
dans le deux parties n'avaient pas
vraiment de chance
ok et en général je crois que oui toi
doit gagner pas mal de parties à mort
avant qu'il commence je pense que la
fille rose j'assurerai et les un très
grand favori la question alors c'est
souvent si on a besoin de trois points
davantage en entrant en boulettes ou 4
quelque chose comme ça oui
par exemple dans ce championnat régulier
avec tous les joueurs forts quand
quelqu'un joue contre nakamura wade
ormsby cellulite en anglais ouais
avantage quelques points davantage les
crasses presque tout le monde ah ouais
efi russia c'est un des trois ou quatre
meilleurs joueurs de belote du monde
s'est établie oui il ya carsen et
nakamura et lui et je sais pas qui
d'autre peut-être marre des tickets ou
quelqu'un c'est difficile donc donc
c'est un peu la situation hikaru on peut
dire il faut entrer avec 3,4 points au
moins davantage ans paulette et qu'est
ce que tu penses de cette ouverture si
cet espagnol un mot n'avait ça s'est
bien passé pour les blancs il a un peu
plus d espace avec le client de 82 sous
faure et 3
et peut-être une cible sur a6
éventuellement dans les finales
difficile à voir comment les blocs 1,6
au moins nos pions ne bouge pas de si
parfois on met le fou sur f1 jusqu'à 6
et puis à dd je suis pas comme on dit
c'est en français mais des briques
rouges ou en prend un c'est un cognaçais
note de faux contre cavaliers quand on
prend sur des cinq blocs et le pion en
orbite des percées les prêtres eux ce
sont des percées bull je crois que vous
jamais entendu ça avant c'est la
première fois pour moi
bon on va moins parler du fait que je
suis pas qualifié pour faire ce set
commentaires et on va continuer à
regarder le jeu qui se déroule ici donc
moi si j'avais les blancs je voudrais un
tour sur des uns pour m'aider à jouer
avec 4,5 mais le pion à cinq a besoin de
baby sitter c'est un peu dommage
ça devient compliqué c'est vrai on peut
prendre un point à 9,5 m
le cavalier mal classés quand il pousse
si c'est un brise ouais ouais je pense
que c'est peut-être ok pour les blancs
si les noirs prennent sur à 5 mais
j'avais peur de m'être mmm à tour sur
des 1 et laissé les noirs prendre sur à
5 avec la dame puisse y avait hors jeu
est ici après cavaillé c'est sain qu'il
y avait cette menace de d5 et je pense
que ça que wayne ne pouvait pas tolérer
donc il bouge ça d'insurgés 3 et
maintenant ils visent eux 500 bouger le
pion f donc il joue avec les pièces ici
ou 5 pour ouvrir le le le fou ces deux
je pense que ça doit être le plan ici
mais le cavalier devient intéressant
ouais s'il arrive à mettre le cas
veiller sur eux cinq pendant que le
cabba et noir est encore sûr à 5 sa
limite beaucoup son retour au jeu c'est
difficile de devoir et qu'est ce que les
noirs peuvent faire cavaillé 17 il ya
d'indécis ça n'aide pas où ça ça me
donne pas un bon look ce projet un pion
sur les droits à cran on va être attaqué
la déficit lundi
[Musique]
normalement tu bouges pas les gens
évitent il qu est ce qu il aurait
peut-être une idée du jouet cavaillé h 5
sur 5
et puis qu'on l'aide d'un bouche de
jouer t5 et garder les choses un peu
fermé je suis d'accord donc ici j'aurais
peut-être jouer ça et puis a cédé 5
c'est pas merveilleux non plus
il y aurait aussi cette idée de dames
chez cinq peut-être mais échanger jouer
cavalier c4 pas c'était possible quelque
chose comme ça donc tour des seins ça
aussi pour moi c'est une mauvaise
nouvelle pour fil rouge à parce que la
tour était déjà bien placé donc s'il
trouve que tour damiens et c'est fort ça
veut dire que c'est vraiment fort oui
les noirs ne peuvent pas jouer cavalier
e 5 ici non pourquoi pas a donc les
blancs échanges cavaillé une fois et
puis jouer quatre blabla place un qe paf
ouais c'est dur donc cavaillé h5 c'est
pour ça qu'il a joué j'ai six parce
qu'il y avait besoin d'eux
2ce tactique ce tempo de jouer cavalier
h5 ont certains cas intéressant le
cavalier à 5 est peut-être encore plus
encore plus piégés sur a3 qu'ils ne
l'étaient sur 1,5 ou encore pire placer
ses coups oui et même évité 4,5 et le
dernier coup très fort maintenant il a
la colonne paix pour utiliser aussi
et soudain j'ai l'impression que les
noirs sont gagnants mais je sais pas
comment il a fait c'est un inconvénient
kevin hill et il est il et la gelée mis
dans ce cadre robe là ils essaient de
taper pour ressortir mais vous
l'entendez peut-être pas
bon si les noirs aux frais et une
échange de dames ce serait très bon pour
les noirs d'aller en finale ici oui
probablement
ces quatre citoyens il ya toujours
cavaillé ces deux je pense que de toute
façon s'ils jouaient 2e set où dame 6 ou
quelque chose les blancs allaient jouer
d'un mât 4 pour attaquer cette
construction à trois c4 qui est faible
donc il a dit ok je vais sur a6 toyoda 4
si j'ai le choix donc maintenant ça
devient question de cavaillé ces deux
tours deux dames c3 c'est bizarre
[Musique]
après s'être cloud et on te dira qu'ils
sont différents les noirs ou ont
peut-être perdre le cavalier mais dit
[Musique]
ouais
malheureusement cavaillé b4 tour ces
trois cavaliers à 6 tours prend b2 c'est
ça le problème avec double clouage donc
il sacrifier le pont depuis en c4 et je
vais commander ses trois nièces 1,5
ça c'est un problème assez grand et gros
problème et il perd tout son temps
maintenant chez rhodia
mais ça sera passée les plans ont la
case e 2 pour bloquer s'ils veulent ou
les tours de roues est finie
est-ce que ce pass prise en b3 à b2 ça
va ouais c'est un truc de boulettes si
oui il y avait aussi quatre secondes
peut-être il hésite ray mais oui tu peux
hésiter entre temps car maintenant il
veut jouer tour g1 je pense sur 36
fonctionner madame f un échec et puis
prendre sur b52 compliqué ouais moi sur
mon bolide ça aurait marché ça a pris 25
secondes à wailly pour trouver ces coups
6 et s'est pas encore complètement
éclaircies
c'est comme position normale mais roy en
d4 qingdao il doit faire de la place il
veut faire de la place f4 autre échec et
mat à la dame bien joué bien jouer où ça
devient déjà dur pour vivre aux siens 3
0 3 0
maintenant la question 1 quand est ce
qu'ils arrivent à faire son premier
point
la première partie parce que tu ne sais
jamais combien de temps ça va prendre
quand ils entrent dans le match ça sera
plus heureux mais il faut qu'ils ne le
perd pas trop de points jusqu'ici
oui à jouer vraiment impeccable pas
d'erreur pas de chance il y avait un
moment là où fille roja était devenu
actif et puis c'était cette manoeuvre
dame 17 qui a qui a retourné le jeu mais
en fait c'était vrai il n'y avait pas
contrôler toutes les cases il avait
juste avant c'est un peu mais il y avait
des trous dans sa position pour
maintenant un carreau cannes
donc c'est la première partie 2 e 4 de
fil rouge à dans ce match donc il change
d'ouverture oui maintenant une structure
très solide
les noirs desseins qu'il ya quatre ans
c'est moins facile
oui oui je suis d'accord j'allais dire
donc c'est la première fois qu'on va
voir
why i jouait de la défense dans ce match
mais peut-être avec cavaillé g4 la
défense est déjà terminée après çà et là
deux fois actif et je suis m c'est tout
recentrer et attendre
même les bleus reprendront g4g kovalev 3
s ils veulent toujours prendre le 6
rien de spécial sous pression
antoine je pensais que je n'ai pas de
nationalité mois que je suis simplement
un être humain et mais ma naissance a eu
lieu aux états unis bon actif toujours
actif un le pion g4 n'est pas beau mais
maintenant on peut prendre g5 jouer trop
millions de consommateurs
on a le temps de comme un effort
constant ah ouais il peut jouer contre
lui ça c'est un peu dommage au tour à 8
ça nous dit ce qu'il veut faire
[Rires]
c'est qu'il veut jouer quelque chose sur
les droits avec h55 ou quelque chose
comme ça c'est ma meilleure prestation
que l'on pourrait parler d'une avantage
blanche ici petit avantage que la
structure est meilleur bien supérieure
[Musique]
pour l'instant surtout qu'est ce qu'elle
cherche cette dame d'emblée trois
changer tous les to à ok ok c'est vrai
que c'est peut-être simplement pour
contrôler eux un j avais pas pensé moi
j'avais pensé d'un b 3 mais j'y pense et
ça pas l'air très fort d'un b3 les les
noirs peuvent jouer pouces et 8 s'ils
veulent et puis
ça donne rien dé témoigner là la dame
tacleur si tu peux aussi ça que les
pions comme et 2c de changer de tout
temps peut-être dame h4 ici pour être en
contact avec cette répétition d'un
madame h4
notre coup mais aussi avec cette idée
que si les tours sont échangées et les
noirs veulent être en bonne position
avec leurs dames contrôler des cases
noires avec la dame est peut-être la
colonne c'est vrai mais à la fin du
combat noire
twf seuil est de tenir la position parce
qu'il n'y a pas de plan actives
peut-être refusé de changer le sac parce
que c'est vrai et puis damages 4 peut
suivre quand même et voudra pas vraiment
mettre les deux pieds ensemble au centre
il avait déjà commencé le pion de
changer tous les tours probablement
c'était impressionnant juste échangé un
au sol puis jouer dame de immédiatement
et ça va pour les blancs mais peut-être
il voulait vraiment jouer avec tam et
cavaliers et pas juste échangé les dames
et jouer cavalier contrefout pur parce
que peut-être il n'a pas assez davantage
pour gagner avec juste le cavalier oui
en général besoin de décider les blancs
peuvent jouer avec audi et a pas si
longtemps qu'ils veulent ouais ce sont
les blancs qui se dessine c'est comme ça
que ça change eh oui comme je l'avais
dit qu'en plein tour contre jeu avec
vous
bon ben donc on peut dire qu'on voit
pour la première fois la défense de
voiliers et ça va ça tiens on va
circulation unidirectionnelle je sais
pas c'est juste une traduction grossière
ok bon on demande pourquoi nous
commentant en français bat voir une
réponse c'est que c'est la chaîne chasse
com/fr bonne réponse antoine méo si on
pourrait dire c'est que pour la
commentaires rendent en allemand il n'y
a pas eu assez de france ouais donc on
fait pas de commentaires en allemand
parce qu'il n'y avait pas assez de
personnes qui regardaient les allemands
parlent trop bien l'anglais apparemment
et les français peut-être pas autant
parce que nous devons pas français mais
pensez bien cela donc plus belle les
commentaires en français sur la chance
et puis aussi pour pour les commentaires
anglais on pourrait dire que nous sommes
pas assez bons comment commente ariste
ils ont préféré
monsieur wrench pour les commentaires en
anglais home adam rudolph
ouais bah ouais c'est que c'est
simplement que vous préfériez kevin
c'est pour ça que vous écoutez les
commentaires que vous les suivez en
français ok c'est bien bon nouvèl
nouveaux pions isolé pour les noirs
et il défend encore c'est encore l'air
paf assez pour les noirs
moi j'aimerais pas jouer contre la dame
blanche sur des six ou dix huit 8 tout
ça comme des personnes pour le 4e volet
de 6h à 4 1
mais si les blancs jouer comme d'amd si
soudaine des 8 es ce que tu aimes bien
d'un match cette saison
ça donne ça donne une répétition en face
ouais ok donc les noirs l'heure alors je
tiens à cette répétition la dame des
huit jouer ok donc on va voir de f2
parce qu'alors si on prend sur b2 roi g3
et c'est foutu mais il doit jouer sur
dame ces deux échecs chaque fois que le
roi est sûre f-215 survoltée
ok
ça va j'essaie donc c'était c'était nul
en fait tu pouvais pas échappé à ça
mais pour l'instant peu dire que pays a
commencé le match en très bonne forme et
que j'ai rose et cherche encore ouais
du studio
des fois on oublie que quand quelqu'un
est un joueur aussi fort que les raisins
le moment que tu as un adversaire de
niveau comparable et que je pas très
bien je peux avoir l'air d'un jour parce
qu'il te faut des joueurs forts il
il te ils font semblant leurs
adversaires comment dire tu vois je veux
aller
oui un joueur fort dans l'impression que
son intérieur est un oui oui oui et un
adversaire assez faible c'est tout ce
qu'il faut trouver pour avoir l'air pour
paraître fort quoi il faut juste rouler
quelqu'un qui sait absolument pas jouer
et puis puis tu lui joue du joue contre
lui devant tes copains est à l'air super
fort mauvais jours sont là pour soutenir
penser le premier des quatre de wailly
qui a gagné deux parties avec 4 mais
quand même il
il regarde ce que fit rouge a prévu pour
d4 et puis ils attaquent
ok bon qu'est-ce qui est noir peuvent
faire d'habitude contre les 4h 4 je ne
comprends rien de ces lignes de la scène
voilà on ne voit blanc restos ne
commencent à stocker avec deux bios sur
l'ale où les noirs sont plus forts oui
et non de l'autre côté édition c'est
complètement bizarre
et puis je vois maintenant que nous
sommes à mi temps pour les parties de
cinq minutes dont 45 minutes de passer
45 minutes encore et après ça passe
toujours au contrôle plus vite de cinq
minutes à trois minutes et puis après à
une minute
d'ailleurs il n'y a eu ni derrière un v6
1 seulement des deux entreprises mais
aussi bien qu'à l'étranger 4 vous g4
commun était fraîche
ok donc par exemple tourbe et un gilet
projet quatre fous projet 4k veille et
des trois échecs sur roy afin notamment
de 3 et sur roy eu deux fous j'ai cadré
staff 3 et des complications d'adressés
bien pour le cavalier avec deux dames g1
[Musique]
je crois que notre armée chinoise
calculé même d' inhumain calcul
exactement ça il avait déjà deux minutes
de moins cette partie donc
ce n'est pas un bon signe quand on leur
donne ce faux noms n'ont pensé et 2
minutes puis trouvé que tous les
tactiques vont pour elle et rza et puis
donner son fou hein c'est pas amusant
parce que normalement il faut changer
angers sco pour avoir un mois sinon pas
on n'a pas vraiment d'attac
ouais je pensais aussi qu'il ya une
interne ici où les noirs peuvent
sacrifier un cavalier sur quatre pour
jouer ac 5 et cetera mais ça n'arrive
pas là cette partie on lâche 5
elle sait si c'est peut-être assez
souvent c'est la même chose parce qu'à
la fin de compte
activis ce flou ouais je pensais si on
joue et je pensais à activer la torah
fuite mais si je joue à 5 pour les noirs
les blancs jouent h 6 x suite
et puis le fou ne sortira plus jamais
donc alors j'ai pensé à 6 peut-être pour
vraiment être sûr d'ouvrir à cologne f
mais aussi de pouvoir libérer le fou
éventuellement si on veut ok mais jouent
à 4 à 3 et mais le cavalier sur b4
comment voit il a même des quatre pour
saddam et c'est pas facile de de la
chasse et de menottes plus normalement
quelqu'un fait des jeux de mots avec nos
noms c'est impressionnant
oui aujourd'hui on nous apprendre des
mots des percées tous moi avec les
blancs ce que j'aimerais jouer c'est fou
j'ai quatre et je pense qu'il a joué
roy f1 pour pouvoir jouer fou j'ai 400
cavaliers detroit est peut-être c'est
mon imagination
mais c'est comme ça que je penserai à
n'ont pas pas de bouger 4 pour moi ça va
après et bien il est complètement
tranquille a complètement tranquille
moi j'appelle ça un pion traître le pion
sur afsset pions traître parce que c'est
évident qu'il qu'il aide les noirs par
les blancs un jour nous représente
c'est même pas une sacrifices on peut
toujours le prendre mais pour le moment
et nous aident donc on le laisse sans
même jouer la partie juste c'est super
quand quelqu'un abandonne et le matériel
était ghana spa guerre ça c'est comme un
idéal aux échecs
on pourrait dire mais c'était à peu près
égales oui mais tu es content
ohlala j'ai rien compris à la fin dit
quelqu'un basse c'est à peu près juste
que la position blanche était et est
trop moche ouais il pouvait pas
organiser ces pièces il pouvait pas
défendre colonnes f
s'ils jouent f3 pour pour faire pour
parce qu'il peut pas défendre f26 mais
le pian sur f3 éventuellement les noirs
vont jouer g4 et puis c'est fini mais
presque toutes les pièces noires sont
dans l'attaqué si on regarde rien c'est
compréhensible
cette transition pour le moment ils
changent le d'ouverture chaque partie
maintenant on a une française de ou de
wailly et j'attends j'attends moi avoir
un joueur dire ok dans cette ouverture
j'ai des belles positions je vais le
répéter et je vais être obligée à
trouver une réponse
je prends que les deux ne sont déjà
théoriquement peuvent jouer ce que
toutes les positions
c'est pour ça que ce n'est aucun
problème
changer de voie mais par exemple si on
avait eu une très belle position avec la
série viennent pour dire aux joies et
oui jouer encore des 4 est ce que firent
où jade incertaine on dirais ok je
répète là où j'ai eu une belle position
oui mais dans ce cas pas changé donc il
ne faut pas espérer d'avoir la même
ligne ok qu'y at il de mieux aux échecs
ben nous sommes dont le speech à ce
championnat junior donc c'est pas les
lamentations de leur femme et ses les
lamentations de leur maman ici petits
petits changements
ce sont les maires de wailly défi roja
qui vont pleurer sur leurs enfants se
font détruire
alors qu'est ce qui se passe ici les
plans je veux que les c5
ce
et c'est pas dans le film et dans le
film n'y a pas d'échec non plus un bon
vous pouvez pas échanger les dames avec
damas six parce que sinon il n'aurait
jamais la possibilité de jouer b6 pour
contrôler cette case
sinon les noirs ont beaucoup échangé et
d'un missile donc l'idée sur cavaliers
bessette c'est simplement un v6 et puis
reprendre le pian quand le quand le
cavalier s'échappe et noir menace
peut-être cavaillé prendre des quatre
ici oui ou juste rendre aux cinq ans ça
s'est bien passé pour le moins ouais si
on voit cavaliers bi tra détroit les
blancs n'ont en rien accompli oui il
vient de cette fois d'un tramway damas
quatre ça devrait aller
1 ok les plans peuvent-ils jouer g4
parce que ouais il le faut parce qu'il
le faut
je ne sait jamais s'il faut jouer
cavalier à 6o retourner aux 7 pour jouer
cavalier g6 à ce que fit rouges à
chamonix beckham aux caraïbes et 4 quoi
il va pas prendre sur l'a2 qu'est ce
qu'il va faire un cavalier c2 prend avec
cinq prix laisse prise d'un mas 2 et
puis quelque chose qu'un fou g5 et car
il est défendu d'un bep cinq est menacée
et cetera
est-ce que tu t'attends encore un match
serré georg après après le 3 0
oui début oui je n'étais pas sûr si ça
va rester un 3 045 mais trois mois et
demi ouais bon cette partie c'est
important je pense parce que il vient de
gagner sa première partie donc on va
voir si le psy montre son sa vraie forme
pour aujourd'hui
maintenant qu'il a t-il un point nous
avons là peut-être est raciste
nous avons là en bas
quelque chose que oui a dit il a dit qu'
il aime le style de fille rocha qui joue
sans peur c'est toujours bien ainsi ce
jeu bien j'ai bien de ne craint donc
dans ce cas c'est clair ce qui ne
pensait et maintenant cavalier b3 et
défendu donc les blancs défendent à 2
avec tours à didactique il est noir veut
jouer quoi h 5 tours j'ai vite quelque
chose comme ça éventuellement la tour
doit jouer sinon c'est difficile de
gagner mais le pion à 7 700 reprises
dont je t'aimais bien la séance et de
bruit ouah donc il va juste rock et
très simple avec ça est ce qu'il ya des
scénarios il pourrait jouer d'am dam à
deux tours à un cavalier b4 pas vraiment
parce que les blancs pourraient jouer
dame c3 donc ok fille roja et le ils
avancent maintenant et j'aimerais
échanger prendre le pion à 2 oui mais
dans ce cas de 9,4 contre je ouais je
laissais l'a46 quelque chose comme
saddam six échecs prendre sur ses soins
ouais pas clair oui va investir ces
derniers c'est de sa dernière grande
pensée de la partie 35 secondes et lui
en reste 34
il va prendre sur 1 200 échanger s'en
fout e set
c'est à dire les blancs peuvent prendre
sur 17
sûrement mais je veux jouer tour b8000 à
savoir la même pensée et oui c'est fait
probablement c'est également ce que le
droit est aussi bien défendu avec le
soir ne se retourne donc il a réussi à
échanger son cavalier au lieu de s'en
fout ok les blancs doit trouvent doivent
trouver quelque chose parce que c'est
encore un petit peu désagréable ce pion
b2 défendue par la tour la tour défendue
par la reine personne qui peut bouger
c'est pas parfait ça mettre la pression
ouais ouais c'est bien il fallait faire
quelque chose avec le cavalier en f3 qui
n'attaquent est rien voilà qui attaquent
aller sur f 4 h 5 maintenant dans le
pion au scot
pour p 3 qu'est ce qu'ils cherchent là
je ne sais pas même chose et puis il
donne la possibilité de tours c'est
cette eau aux blancs qui avant le tour
sur bessette et fondé ça c'était c'était
bien pour la je crois qu'il joue et où m
ouais donc avec quatre secondes
ça n'a pas l'air très bien pour lui
passer à tour ces deux qui est aussi aux
prises donc fait peut pas prendre le fou
si la tour blanche ou julien vous g5 et
puis d'un retourné roger si le côté
gauche et yahya yahya le répéter
pourquoi doit-il répéter un thème des
trois échecs à 5 tours série de quelque
chose comme ça ok ok ok oui oui je le
vois
ok voilà fil rouge avait été secondes
pour résoudre ça retombe
c'est pas possible sous un nul on
n'arrive pas possible vraiment dans
cette position compliquée avec des
seconds tous les deux ont vu que c'était
nul comme ça il paraît que les
répétitions
voilà comme ça je me demande ça par
exemple weei la dernière fois qui a eu à
eux cinq projets il a joué une très
belle partie dans l'espagnol puis rogère
retourne sur cinq et joue cavalier ces
trois au lieu de jouer l'espagnol ça je
comprends pas un peu moi parce que si
j'étais très content avec le position
que j'avais je retournerai moi j'ai
obligerait qui rouge à me montrer
quelque chose d'autre qui là parce que
peut-être il n'a pas autre chose dans
l'espagnol sait maintenant c'est du
classique je ferais la même chose que
toi aussi ok mais peut-être c'est de la
m simplement changé d'ouverture 18 ans
c'est juste pour se donner ce pour se
donner plaisir oui pourquoi pas c'est
possible parce que dans un certain sens
c'est plus intéressant c'est peut-être
aussi de voir comme l'entraînement
un adversaire très fort dans un match
sérieux on la connaissait pas mal de
positions différentes aussi pourrait
prendre quelque chose
bon ça c'est une position classique n'y
a pas trop de personnes qui jouent cette
partie en anglais on appelle quatre
cavaliers je sais pas les noms des
ouvertures mais ya pas beaucoup de
personnes qui jouent cette position
maintenant pour les blancs mais oui je
lui ai vus jouer c'est avant tout raison
je réfléchissais la même question
je me rappelais sur le nom de ces partis
c'est comme le seul joueur de 2700 août
a vu cette position
ouais je joue moins
c'est très difficile pour les plantes
d'activer le phocéen case mois attendant
le père de fois on cherche toujours
sur les quinze zones supplémentaires
ouais donc les noirs ont bloqué toutes
les diagonales noir avec leurs pions
c'est fait exprès à 4 à 5
c'est ce qui m'arrive à l'esprit oui
mais c'est bien d'échanger le pion à
mais n'arrivent toujours pas trop beau
qu'il est noir par exemple juste je vais
voter se trouvaient sept ans donc tu me
laisserais avec les noirs tu me
laisserais échanger sur b6 et puis tu
défendrait le plan b 6 mais parce que
celle des systèmes de l'attaqué droit
une fois
ouais et mon four est passif mais au
moins j'ai une cible quelque part donc
pour moi c'est un petit quelque chose
une petit quelque chose d'avoir ça ok
cavaillé h4 et bien sûr f5 damev 8c
prend des 4g si c'était le calcul ce
serait positif pour le blanc ouais parce
que maintenant le fou peut aller y aura
trois au b2 et et se faire sentir
oui je n'ai aucune idée pourquoi le
priant de 15 ans oui si ce n'était pour
jouer quelques tactiques avec g 6 mai
puis n'a pas fait
ah ouais avec le fou sur ses seins il
n'y avait jamais g6 je me trompe donc
donc j'ai aucune idée pourquoi il a pris
sur des quatre 4 ans je trouvais de ici
cinq joueurs quatre donc peut-être qu'à
veiller à eux trois ici là il ya comme
ses trois un peu bizarre 3 1 mais ce
n'est pas grave tantôt b1
si je prends et 4,5 ouvre de g2 c'est
pour ça que j'ignorais mon pions des
quatre parce que j'avais toujours
il ya aussi la chance de prendre aux 9,5
oui je vois il y avait aussi des messes
3 qui était intéressant aussi pour
prendre sur et h6 meybon fo b2 prix sur
f5 mauvais structure pour les blancs
mais mais très belle paire de faux pour
le moment à les résas rigole hyrule hall
très content c'est bien compris le la
procession comme c4 je le vois
tambouriner sur sa table il est
tellement content choix donc selon lui
ce four b2 doit être un très mauvais
coup ci saluant si content ce petit
changement positionnelle produit c'est
comme un blender incroyable qu'on puisse
jouer un coup comme fou b2 et finalement
ce 4 aie aie aie aie d'où les blancs
doivent prendre ça s'ils permettent des
cinqs etc
super mal ouais ok je commence à
comprendre le bonheur de fil rouge à ces
pauvres fous
déjà difficile de trouver des coupables
pour les plans
il ya des cases pont pour une deuxième
cavaliers ses 52 sec le seul haut à
double voie les noirs ont plein de 15
maintenant et je prendre le pion dessin
continue le jeu l'as toujours si on
pense à la défense des blancs si en
échange un des mauvais faux ça rend
simplement plus facile à t'acheter noir
de jouer contre le mauvais fou qui reste
n'est ce pas toujours une couleur
pratiquement way et ouais donc ça
devient encore plus simple que ça n'aide
vraiment pas d'échanger un fou même si
c'est un mauvais faux site transition
entre une intro betron à mesdames à 4
qu'est ce qui se passait dans ma 4l
ouattara que tout ça va
j'ai l'impression que le score on va se
serrer la 4 à 3 après sa partie contre
est de fous afin de trois on arrive à
s'en sortir
un même ça
d'un peu sortir même sur des cinq
maintenant ciel veut est ici après tour
à un d'amd 5
c'est très fort les plans devraient
prendre sur 1 3 les noirs peuvent
prendre sur f5 aussi c'est de plus en
plus à se donne ce fou mais là je rate
essonne c'est quoi le problème c'est
tour ces deux par exemple autour un
[Musique]
hockey ce prénom
y a pas de cours mais n'arrivent pas un
seul instant sortie en quoi je crois
encore ali riza ouais bon il ya toujours
3 j'ai vu ça mais je sais pas à l'idée
c'est pas l'idée ne peut vraiment été ok
c'est pour ça qu'on le voyait pas un et
résonne toujours contents non maintenant
il a l'air sérieux et oui il ne change
pas d'expressions jusqu'ici où il faut
des yeux plus fin que les miens port
pour voir ses expressions projet
d'exposition tant d'autres le match
ok on va finir en pole est ici le fou en
f1 est encore mauvais cavaillé e3 c'est
possible oui et blanc vont sacrifier sa
fille de tours et non moi je comprends
qu'ils ne qui n'abandonne pas chez
rochas il a encore quelques petites
chansons boulette or après cela
peut-être damas trois tout ce que tu
veux
oui sur cavaillé troyat roi f2 au don
quarrie et d un échec alors ouais très
bien ok il nous reste encore 16 minutes
pour les parties de cinq minutes donc
peut-être deux partis qui restent ici
et oui il a retourné un avantage de
trois points
ouais j'imagine
maintenant c'est probablement si on
entrait en boulettes maintenant oui ok
donc urgent art on pourrait dire que le
match était qu'à lens est égal en ce
moment oui a égalisé très vite avec ce
score de 5-2
elle loue gaz 68 demande pour nos
pronostics pour le rapide pour moi
toutes les parties sont très rapides ici
vérifier à quel nom il ya aussi une
question sur l'écran qui est auquel
détracteurs répondent c'est à quel
niveau est-ce que tu considères
quelqu'un comme un super grand maître
2700 ans de 1732 1809 1500 mah au 6 mai
[Musique]
mais les catr attente encore plus
pour moi être plus que 2800 ça veut dire
que tu es candidat pour le championnat
du monde est donc super grand maître ça
doit être un peu moins que ça un peu
plus de personnes doivent être dans
cette conversation là donc je suis
d'accord avec toi moi aussi je dirais
2700 simple cite une chiffre ronde c200
plus haut que 2500 pour le titre de
grand maître donc c'est déjà une une
grande différence entre 2700 et 2500 et
maître international ses 2400 donc c'est
100 points entre maître international et
grand maître et ses 100 points ça
représente déjà beaucoup et à ce que
c'est un chien qui ne me dit plus on
avance plus les points représentent
d'expérience de connaissance de force
donc entre 2500 et 2600 et dirais que
c'est c'est beaucoup plus difficile que
entre 2400 et 2500 alors entre 2500 et
2007 sens et c'est un grand c'est une
grande différence de niveau c'est moi je
comprendrai facilement s'il y avait une
autre titre quelque part là c'est
simplement que fait de ne pas décider
d'avoir un autre titre presque dans
l'histoire de la fédération
internationale ils ont toujours été
intéressé gagner de l'argent pour les
les frères qui sont ouais les frais
d'applications pour tout ça
ouais ouais
on comprend que deux tours le vertueux
moi l'idée c'est de mettre le fou sur g7
et puis espérer que tout ira bien qu'au
pire qu'à ça devient un est indien qui
le seraient aussi content de jouer je
vois une observation que oui a l'air de
jouer à 2 heures du matin en essayant
pas de déranger les autres et faire trop
de bruit et en fait c'est vrai je pense
qu'ils jouent à une heure du matin en
chine
ça dépend exactement où il est mais
quelqu'un d'autre ça puis rouge à lui et
en turquie ça doit faire quoi
huit heures du soir peut-être quelque
chose comme ça 51 8 heures ben oui wind
3h vite c'est toujours pour jouer à cinq
mois j'ai joué des des coûts de café
comme ça en anglais on dit que c'est les
les coûts de joueurs de café c'est parce
que en europe en 19ème siècle je meurs
des parties d'échecs été joué dans les
cafés ouais donc ça veut juste dire que
tu joues comme un joueur qui n'a rien
appris depuis 200 ans
moi je moi je pense pas que les lots
s'invente
si tu regardes sur la liste et des
joueurs de des top 100 et tu regardes
les cotes maintenant pour plastie c'est
pas le placement et plastron t'es même
pas plus haut qu'il ya disons oui à mon
avis ce qui change c'est qu'il n'y ait
plus de joueurs forts qu'avant
ouais c'est tout simple un point que
inflation permanence et plus tôt ce jour
fort un certain niveau
ça devient difficile pour tout le monde
tu vois que qu'on a pas beaucoup de
joueurs avec plus de 2800 prenez avec
l'arrivée des ordinateurs très fort et
les basques que tout le monde à la
maison c'est plus facile de faire
progresser jusqu'à un certain niveau
ouais c'est vrai qu'avant les
ordinateurs on n'avait pas plus que dix
mâts k2700 c'est vrai mais mais ça fait
déjà presque vingt ans cette époque tu
ordinateur et si tu regardes tu peux
voir que c'est comme tu regarde
quelqu'un comme dominguez tu regardes sa
cote et tu regardes sa plus haute cote
c'était à peu près la même il y a huit
ans ou quelque chose comme ça il était
placé exactement le même monde il était
ces principes à que c'est pas que c'est
pas qu'il a descendu monté avec ça mais
mais aussi si on a une petite frimousse
distribution normale de joueurs et tu
dis qu'il ya je sais pas une certain
pourcentage qui auront 2700 alors cité à
deux fois plus de personnes qui jouent
tour à deux fois plus de 2700 aussi les
échecs sont devenus plus populaires avec
l'internet
en ce qu'on fait maintenant cette petite
preuve
ouais sûrement il ya plus de
professionnels qu'avant et plus de fans
c'est tout ça non sacrifier un billion
ouais le pion aux 5 va être extrêmement
faible papa papa vivre très longtemps à
mon avis ouais les noirs peuvent
chercher quelque chose comme cavalier
prend f2 ou c3 quand les blancs essayer
de gagner le plan le pion aux 5 quelques
tactiques pour sacrifier le cavalier
puis avancez 4,9 de 3,81 ce que ceux
comme un des dossiers cette décision est
tout tout en bois ok il a joué tous les
trois très vite aussi bon
au tous les coups que tu es ce que tu
apprécies c'était la ligne importante
et alors là je comprends pas ce que ce
que wailly pense faire cette partie est
urgent à supplanter nouveau riz dit non
non non non non non et bien maintenant
les blancs ont un pion de plus et une
mauvaise position pour pour le roi noir
et le pian f4 aussi qui tombent ici même
tournée et elle est mobilisée le 6 à les
noirs prennent comme ça et puis après
2004 ils ont tous les trois requis
mais bon c'est certain oui ça ça pique
h4 on veut pas jouer à 6 et ouvrir le
roi de l'autre côté aussi
mais sinon sinon tout tombe sur la
droite
donc ils étaient obligés maintenant
jouer oui voudraient jouer d'un 9 3 mai
et dames 1 prend ses 3 c'est pas évident
pinda 9,3 dams est oui à l'amphi rouge à
dance dance dames 7 c à danser il est
super concentré là pour la phase
boulette il a arrêté de danser
bien que sa position était merveilleuse
ok alors encore une partie des sommes
encore une partie est encore 4,5
donc on reprend un peu l'espagnol non
oui 4,4 cavale hélas bien jusqu'au
troisième coup depuis georges pour jouer
les 3 c'est vraiment surprenant pour moi
combien échanges très bien servi demandé
je me rappelle d'avoir s'appelait noir
bien joie ce qui est marrant c'est que
oui va faire la même chose
hu wei pourrez y jouer exactement la
même partie qui vient de perdre mais
avec un impôt de plus mais est ce que ça
lui tente
oui ça lui tente ça c'est pour moi ça
c'est bizarre parce que c'est comme si
la seule chose qu'il veut répéter c'est
la partie qui a joué la pire parties
qu'il a jouées en fin de compte c'est la
seule partout où il était vraiment
détruit là non il y avait une autre dent
dans last indien mais aux ovnis rouge à
10h je peux jouer à 5 avant toi ouais
ouais mais le problème c'est que jouer à
quatre ou à cinq c'est pas si bien
tout le monde veut le faire on a vu des
gambier roi en étant enfant mais c'est
vraiment ce pas très bien d'avancer le
pian f
le blitz surtout avec le bio un rêve de
c'est surtout dans les finales quand
l'adversaire commence à montrer avec les
pièces on commence à sentir
ouais donc c'est ce sont les noirs qui a
accompli avec 5 mais je pense qu'ils
doivent garder assez de pression sur f2
pour garder le cavalier sur f3
s'il est blanc parvenaient à jouer
cavalier à 3h 4 quelque chose comme ça
sans perdre le puck en f2 ce serait
les blancs qui prendrait charge de la
position pour louga mais cott mon fils
et ça doit être dans les 2300 je regarde
plus parce que je joue plus depuis
quatre cinq ans évidemment quand je
jouais beaucoup c'était 2400 pour avoir
le titre deux amis maintenant je suis
pas un peu moins et chaque point comme
blitz peut-être 2200 ou 2300 parce que
je suis pas très fort on glisse donc est
ce que je serais capable de le battre je
sais pas probablement pas une partie
s'ils ont joué une dizaine peut-être de
toute façon moi je cherche huawei c'est
tout ce que j'aime jouer moi moi aussi
dias arena keynes deux fois par semaine
tous les vendredis 9 heures 9 heures du
soir paris pratiquement et dernier
vendredi
bonjour huawei et un autre par la
majorité des partis est très
intéressante même si j'en ai perdu
beaucoup
ouais je pense que c'est un peu ce que
fit rouge à aywaille y cherche ici dans
leur match en changeant chaque chaque
partie d'ouverture peut-être mais j'ai
pensé que ces deux jeunes si vous voulez
savoir si un coût et dans l'esprit
linkin chasse il faut juste se demander
si c'est un mauvais coup ci c'est un
mauvais coup voilà c'est dans l'esprit
donc j'ai quatre oui ce serait un très
mauvais coup ici pour les blancs je sais
pas même comment ils pourraient le jouer
mais s'il arrivait à le jouer ce serait
terrible donc je pense que c'est bien
dans l'esprit oui
s'il est blanchi 4 dans cette partie
ferroviaire va commencer à danser mais
si tu joues des quatre filles la danse
c'est bien c'est yahia un tournoi de
fisher random en deux heures et demie si
ce match fini en temps moi je vais jouer
sa qualifier je suis déjà comme moi je
sais que tu es déjà qualifié moi j'ai
perdu sur tie break 6 la semaine
dernière
donc ouais surtout après avoir regardé
beaucoup d'échecs ça donne toujours
l'envié de jouer pour moi un temps que
j'aime bien regarder ces des
contractants mai puis à la fin j'ai le
sang qui monte je veux aussi jouer ouais
je suis d'accord avec toi nyoni bas si
c'étaient tous des partis par line on
pourrait arrêter de regarder le match et
orgue et moi on pourrait jouer du fisher
ndom ensemble est juste mettre notre
notre échiquier au dessus de le lard et
on on pourrait regarder fruits rouges à
danser mais pas ses parties de berline
des fois j'ai deux n est pas très
content non non non mais si je vous jure
si les blancs jouent aux clichés 4 il
sera encore plus fâché l'après g4 c'est
le suicide pour le fond angers de jeunes
noirs parce que il faut échanger ici
n'est ce pas on peut pas laisser les
blancs prendre tout l'espace et changer
ça ouvre un peu et et on a tort
on a tort où il a tort difficile linkin
chasse le comprends je comprends ça avec
les quatre jeux c'est même que ben j'ai
fait un jeu fait un stream une fois avec
cabine bourdy dont je sais un peu ça
avec g4 je sais que même il est emporté
à le jouer sur le premier coup parfois
mais comme j'ai dit c'est presque
toujours mauvais
s'il ya un certain moment une position
où c'est bien de jouer j'ai quatre comme
une attaque anglaise dans les night of
alors il dirait que j'ai 4 c'est pas
dans l'esprit parce que c'est une des
seules positions au g4 c'est un bon coup
on n'a pas nécessairement ceux c'est le
style café théâtre s'amuser un peu
ouvrir ma position
la bonne nouvelle pour wii c'est que il
peut répéter avec ce fou j'ai deux fois
3 et soit fille rouge à lui échanges
soit il réussit à faire nul et guingamp
à deux arrêts si tu as assez tant pour
pour nous donner une liste des
faiblesses dans le jeu de kevin contre
il est dangereux
ouais mais mais ils veulent connaître
ses faiblesses oui donc pour sa
[Musique]
déposition tranquille ouais les
positions ou g46 le suicide et puis le
jour a quand même peut-être
il faut juste pour lui donner des cibles
sur le droit il peut jouer g4 tout ce
qu'il veut mais je vais rien bouger
voilà qu'en cabine retourne vous serez
préparer à le battre voulait les
chateurs des 5
c'est bien il faut faire quelque chose
si on si on laisse les blancs jouer at 5
ça doit être jouée des 5 pour les noirs
après qu'est ce qui se passe là en
échange la fuite a ajouté cinq s'est pas
défendu après ok
il est arrivé à égaliser s'il aurait
prions dessins que si le ce lundi noir
entrer dans le jeu et 1 h 4 est urgent
que la bien filmé et a bien fait de
jouer cavalier g6 oui enfin une finale
il y en a pas eu assez de finale
aujourd'hui
oui mais dans le sens que ça pourrait
être cette position 15 secondes contre
15 secondes
comme s'il avait commencé avec une
minute
donc ça sera intéressant à voir si je
veux aussi lui pose des problèmes s'il
ne se passe rien du tout ouais
c'est très serré du temps créée noir les
bleus peuvent s'attendre à 100 points
mais c'est de faire quelque chose les
trois oui maintenant d'un f3 trop
d'espèces non toujours ton eau là c'est
là c'est nul
3-2 probablement déjà en cours tours
peut aller sur f5 aux non pas dans notre
direction
elle a peur du contrôle de jeu tous il
peut prendre il peut échanger ici puis
jouer pour ces 2 ac 4
vingt cinq sont seuls oui aux 5 c'était
toujours faible c'est juste que enfin
ils attaquent mais c'est intéressant de
1,2 commence ouais position très simple
oui c'est vrai et c'est le même sang pyo
eux c'est peut-être possible
oui je sauvais la position si les noirs
avaient un pion f au lieu de pions hc
gagnant pour les noirs où il aurait pu
faire une table tu as vu ça ouais quand
il a bloqué tours 6 oui mais oui s'est
pas emparée de la chance problèmes de
connexion qu'est ce qui s'est passé là
problèmes de connexion c'est pas juste
et firent fille roja n'a pas l'air
content de ce point là il fait comme or
ok c'est la fin des parties cinq minutes
donc un point davantage pour wei y est
je pense que ici on fait une petite une
petite pause de quatre minutes environ
et puis on revient pour les parties de
trois minutes donc très vite
moi je dirais que 5,4 c'est pas tout à
fait assez bien pour voyez il aurait dû
gagner par 2 3 points
dans les cinq minutes
oui bien sûr ouais on aurait pas dû donc
c'est pas c'est pas tout à fait sa faute
là ok bon les gars en sera là en quatre
minutes pour les parties de trois
minutes
[Musique]
ok voilà c'est bien
nous attendons encore le début des
parties de trois minutes mais ça doit
pas tarder les parties de cinq minutes
conclues avec une partie où un point
davantage pour broyer
selon georg il devrait avoir trois
points davantage en entrant ball est
pour faire un match à peu près égale
lamboley j'ai beaucoup vu dominer et des
dernières sorties voilà ça commence et
la dernière partie qu'on a vus c'était
c'était oui qui a perdu sur connexion
dans une finale deux tours nul
complètement nul et soit c'est du
mauvais signe pour plus tard quand ça
devient de plus en plus vite s'il peut
avoir des problèmes de connexion mais
regarde il répète encore il a enfin
trouvé une ouverture qui veut répéter
york c'est l'ouverture mauvais avec g6
il vient de perdre deux parties de suite
et bah oui aurait dû défendre et annulé
la partie précédente avec les blancs
mais aussi c'était une partie où il
n'avait jamais davantage avec les blancs
et ils défendent et ils défendent et
défendez pour faire nul
ok ça ok
prend on qu'est ce que tu attends prend
pourquoi olala 26 secondes pour prendre
le fou menacée mais c'est quoi ça je
crois que c'est un signe que tout sa
confiance
sinon il n'y a pas d'explication
ouais c'est pour être la connexion de
nouveaux peut-être juste pas mais on va
axer ses biens il faut échanger une fois
et puis tu peux être cavaillé e5 qui va
être joué
si les champs dans ce cas 9,5
intéressant c'est quoi s'attendre on
sacrifie l'option qu'est ce qui se passe
parce que se veut prendre date et vite
la position est complètement ouverte les
noirs ici c'est au moins c'est de
compensation ok mais maintenant les
normes peuvent échanger jouer fou à 5 et
tout va bien aussi
ce feu sans qui le g4 il les blogs
un jour mon g4
ouais
un même c'est surprenant
oui parce qu'après j'ai 4 ans reprend
avec la dame de quatre soeurs et leurs
biens
comme si on se pose plutôt restée rincon
jt en général ici serait d'avancer les
pions à la dame pour les noirs oui et
pour les blancs qu'est ce qu'on voudrait
faire ici trouver un moment pour avancer
aussi ce we des services est ce que il
laisse les cases blanches ou le blanc
ouais tantôt réponse est peut-être dame
e6 oui parce que si tu joues comme un
des quatre des cinq n'est pas très
stable
ouais ok bon en fin de compte il est
d'accord qu'est-ce qui se passera le
cogner la dame fall à la saphir ou jacky
fait pas attention là mais sur ce niveau
de quelqu'un de films comme furent aux
yeux ça n'arrive pas souvent très
surprenant
il a pris en mai 7 sans réfléchir me roy
absolument
disons que c'est peut-être un premier
point gagné deux chansons oui et c'est
certainement le la plus grande erreur
que nous avons vu jusqu'ici aujourd'hui
voilà juste dons qu'elle reçoit un peu
la dernière partie cubaine au coeur
d'une connexion ouais c'était un peu
juste dans un certain sens à 3 tient
vraiment à faire marcher cette partie
des 4 chevaliers à trois je ne veux pas
du tout idiot parce que ça sonne comme
une épreuve 5004 ok oui oui ici aussi
les dites poupée 4
intéressant il n'était pas obligé à
apprendre sur ces 6 tous les cours sont
soutenus
non elle a simplement reçu un petit
avantage de structure mais je ne
comprends pas rosiane pris avec le
pionner en ce sens mais les blancs
doivent finir le développement et
pendant ce temps les noirs vont chercher
quelques contres jeu sur l'ale dame je
vois qu'ils jouent pour cavaillé c4
maintenant je pense moi j'ai pensé à b5
et 4 difficile si tu voulais 5 p 4 on
déplore jco 21,4 et vise à casser 5
fois c'est c'ui un peu de pression là
sur b2 commun qu'elles ne prendront
cette fois
les blancs sont décédés soit échangé en
c3 soit jouée qu'à et ses quatre
messieurs comme un de ces quatre prendre
un set au hockey c'est pour ça qu'ils
hésitent et qui trouve autre chose mais
j'ai 5 c'était un peu bizarre pour moi
mais je suis surpris aussi
même le simple port entre son président
quatre à six semaines
alors il doit jouer fouge et 3
probablement
à peut-être fait rosir je vais au g7
après regardez la tension à a fait ça
est très souvent ils trouvent des
solutions assez subtil
il fait très bien d'utiliser les moyens
de tactique pour solutionner le problème
positionnelle voilà bessac non le pion
g5 un peu trop où aller on veut jouer
cavalier 4 sur le prochain coup
certainement temps qu'est ce qui peut
faire à ce qui peut jouer p4 ici
c'est possible un premier couac au
sommet donc en trois sets avec ou sans
échanger les pions à servir sa chance
aux jeunes
ok donc y chocs avaya 5a illégal mais le
pian g2 les fables ici mais il peut même
jouer tour d2 c'est le doublé enfin il
veut échanger tous les tours ce
communiqué trois elle prend des huit
tours d un danger 4 way
non je pense que oui il garde son
avantage et jeanne est entré dans un
autre scénario bullets ouais ils jouent
contre le roi sur g8
maintenant il veut attaquer donc purgea
devrait commencer à échanger les tours
joués c'est alors il cède la colonne des
mais sinon il peut pas sûr porter deux
tours sur la colonne atteindront cet
oncle bios leblond sérieux oui c'est
cette wii s'est perdu donc il doit
attaquer à 6 avant que les problèmes
s'agrandit cela
bon finalement l'avantagé n'est pas
assez grande pour pour voiliers mais
parce qu'il ya des contres ils à tours
j'ai un g3 ici mais et c'est juste qu'il
n'est pas assez davantage pour gagner
cette position un panel sur fort oui toi
j si si si c'est une bonne défense je
crois qu'on me mettait dans un échange
même pas ah oui voyez ne devait pas
donné l'option pour rien
maintenant c'est lui qui doit faire bien
attention et si oui ça c'est pas faire
attention à damner le pion b pour rien
clairement et dès qu'on entre dans le
scénario de paul est maintenant temps
après ce commentaire à la presse que
mater ou vient jouer ça mais songez 4o
quelle bonne idée qui est bonne idée
incroyable je pensais que oui allez
perdre cette partie
ouais parce qu'il a fait six coups pour
pour créer ce match moi je l' ai vu
venir j'ai vu où il construit à matt mai
mais si tu pue ça va jamais se passer
comme ça marche au wpt donc c'est un
match de c1 match de trois parties
maintenant pour voiliers a gagné les
deux premiers partis de trois minutes
on va voir s'il reproduit le 3 0 avec
laquelle il a commencé laisse les
parties cinq minutes on me demande je
pensais tellement bien je pense et c'est
tellement bien mais à l'école au lycée
j'étais dans un lycée bilingue en
allemagne at t la cinquième place des
cours français j'avais même l'histoire
et géographie en france et un moment et
j'ai officiellement passé le
baccalauréat en plus ma mère qui est ni
regret et lycées français un très bien
français ps qu' est-ce que why i est en
train de perdre la partie
jan hajek 6-1 t6 vous prendrez 6 x 4 ou
aqua cavaliers 8 dollars a déçu ses
jouets food et 6.4 le sacré a juste
prendre sur f4 pas si moche que ça même
bien pour les noirs avec la part de food
d'autres pour terminer la petite
histoire
oui oui un jeune a cité un peu ville à
10 ans 90 à 80 % 20 % français donc
quand j'avais 18 ans je parle est rasé
très très bien français mais depuis ce
temps je ne pratique presque pas c'est
pour ça que des fois je ne parle pour
moi mais ça revient c'est je passe un
peu plus de temps en france
qu'est ce que tu penses de cet échange
sur f3 avec le four je pensais que la
paire de fouetter super ici je le voyais
sur bessette je voyais des trucs arrivé
à l'oeil droit
et puis simplement il va les changer et
l'art ce quelque chose en retour
structure blanche est compromise
je comprends aussi ok donc tu aurais pu
voir les voir jouer des deux façons
échanger ou garder oui ok alors quoi
faire avec
je vais à 8 hors est ok maintenant le
cavalier sur ces trois peut aller sur e4
ceux qui ne pourraient pas avec un fou
bessette donc à 4 était un peu plus fort
ici qu avant et qu'est ce que les noirs
pour faire et ils ont beaucoup de choses
prendre il ya beaucoup de choses qui
sont en l'air le fou au f4 le pion b4 le
pion à six et dix lorsque même sur noir
entendent jouer cette fois c'est fini
et si c'est trop d'un bep 7,1 et le
gagnant des classes ça c'est très
important je ne reviens plus de danger
de plomb non je vois un peu de danger
pour les noirs mais c'est vrai
[Musique]
mais si ce n'est pas jouer parce que le
roi devient peu exposé même la question
1 ne laisse pas prendre b2 strictement
ça s'était bien fait je me demandais
s'ils allaient personne et maintenant
les noirs beaucoup de mal de
bardonecchia ce contre le bio un oui
juste d'un v6 et salaires fini pour moi
mais je suis d'accord c'est fini oui il
abandonne toujours content quand il
décide c'est stratégique pour perdre ne
veut pas voir l'exécution ah ok
à troyes encore on va apprendre beaucoup
sur 1,3 finalement elle a trouvé une
ouverture à mais même là elle ne paye
pas ouais
il change tout le temps tout le temps
oui
bon alors si on joue à 3 pourquoi est-ce
qu'on entre dans la position normale
maintenant avec ces échanges sur des
cinq essais 6 c'est la position normale
pour le noir mais avec moins de
problèmes encore moins un problème avec
un cavalier et changer comme ça et pion
à trois ça affaiblit la colonne des très
facile pour les noirs et c'est super je
suis pas comment wailly choisi ces
ouvertures mais à mon avis ils répètent
les pires ouverture et ne respecte pas
ce qui c'est qu'ils sont bien marché
pour lui mais c'est assez d or ici il ya
même un problème de développer le
phocéen
avec un peu de pression sur sur b2 ah si
un coup que tu aimes ça guillaume n'est
ce pas et je changerais la bonne pièce
des blancs la dame et puis trouver les
faiblesses et un l'aider j'aime bien
l'idée sur damas 7 6 lors et prions de 2
d'un v8 sous un système d'âmes à cette
dame 2008 soit 6 8 6
finito
ouais et les blancs ne veulent pas j'ai
changé la dame
évidemment c'est très dangereux pour les
blancs donc voilà s'il pourrait
considérer un fouet cinq créneaux trail
tam ces sites un peu bizarre pour moi le
jour elle s'est peut-être pour jouer des
quatre sur des quatre normalement des
blessés 4 1
je pense qu'il a cherché quelque chose
pour mettre la pression sur les blancs
et une n'a pas trouvé après dams et de
rien de vraiment important
je n'aime pas mon fils tu n'aimes pas
koala d'avancé 6 fumée qui aimerait
jouer ces cinq éventuellement ou
généraux nommés dans cette structure
[Musique]
tours b 1
j'aurais joué tour des deux sauriens
vraiment très passif
oui ton des deux tours à bien
c'est la première fois qu'ils reçoivent
une position plus ou moins au nude ce
qu'est ce que tu aurais pensé d'une
échange de fou de cases blanches 6 et
noir avaient joué pour fou à 6 est-ce
que ça c'est vrai ou pas c'est la bonne
idée mais dès 5h temps après les
championnats
quel contraste cuir ou jackie et si
expressif et huayi impassable juste je
regarde je regarde regarde regarde jouer
pas mal de parties contre les chinois
je rappelle seulement une fois que que
j'ai noté une expression surtout les
joueurs que tu as joué oui c'est
vraiment difficile de les impressionner
ok ici doit échanger pour reprendre son
plan b 2 mai mais ils pensent longtemps
de nouveau il veut jouer d'apcher 5
peut-être alors près d'alger 5 c'est
probablement fougue 4 et sera ok petit
filet ce prêt petit investir en seconde
pour ça et là le vent à 9,6 au patient
c'était pas meilleure je me rappelle
remettre avec beaucoup d'expérience il
disait que le pion c est le meilleur
pierre d'avoir un avantage final le tour
je ne dois pas emmener leurs autres loin
pour le supporter ouais si on joue et 3e
un roi de d2 quelque chose comme ça on
donne pas le pion f
autour noir oui à la tour noire
moi j'ai aussi entendu ça quelque part
mais j'ai aussi entendu que je jouais h4
comme ça c'est celle à l'arrangement des
pions pour faire nul pas pour 19,6 aussi
un petit truc que tu rouge a accès
peut-être pour toi c'était évident mais
pour moi et pour les autres c'est
peut-être pas évident c'était quand il a
joué tour d2 d3 pour pour éviter que le
roi blanc entrent en jeu ça c'est très
important je le montrerai pour une
seconde à la fin de la partie à tout le
monde parce que c'est là la chose que
j'ai vraiment appris de cette partie là
aussi j'ai appris comment réfuté à trois
tons l'ouverture il faut juste jouer
rock et des 5 pour les noirs c'est
facile
mais ça je leur ai trouvé tous à l'eau
c'est comme ça aucune chance et en
affaires parce que le web selon elle il
a aucun nom du chanteur voit cachette je
sais pas we bought écrivions une c6 donc
le voir aller en sucette
dans le livre de voir est ce qui je
pense qu'il appelle aussi ça une
parapluie 1
je me rappelle au labrit un abri c'est
le mot préféré un oui doit faire
attention à la voix avec trois semaines
ça veut dire que la seconde seulement
deux secondes
sinon qu'est ce qui se passe qu'est ce
qui se passe là à changer la position
ah oui surtout recettes il y avait
toujours tour
ces cinq échecs donc ça ne menait à rien
olalala connexions wi d'affaires nul
avant de perdre cette partie
oui ils essaient toujours de gagner je
pense un tour à tour est fini c'est bien
5à très bien très bien
j'avais peur que qu'on allait voir
oui perdre à temps dans cette position
avec un pion de plus et ça m'allait pas
donné une bonne sensation ça à temps en
cours à la prochaine partie dans un
moment je veux juste montrer cette chose
instructif ou est-ce que c'est ok pour
moi sommes ici dans cette position-là la
tour à l'air active sur rade et en
général on veut le plus d'espacé entre
sa tour et le roi blanc pour avoir moi
mais ici ils changent de côté pour la
tournée va jusqu'à d2 et c'est parce que
quand le roi blanc veut entrer veut lui
bloqué f3 et puis quand le roi retourne
et lui prend à eux deux et comme ça
c'est difficile pour les blancs de
sortir le roi c'est super cette
technique non
les clés pour défendre ce type de finale
deux tours avec pierre de moi parce que
très souvent on reçoit cette finale avec
contre le pion à je ne sais pas pourquoi
mais ça arrive très souvent dit nous on
demande cgt élèves malheureusement je
vais pas le temps pour pour avoir des
élèves d'échec parce que j'ai un travail
plus ou moins normale à de radio avons
donc il me reste simplement pas assez
d'énergie
je les gens mais plus car ils toujours
entre 0 et 0,1 comme ça c'est un grand
privilège d'être tourné là-bas aussi
c'est gentil de dire comme ça oui comme
ça on est unique au monde
c'est bien
bon en faisant changer quelque chose
donc le jouet fossé de cette partie avec
présent des quatre écoles
maintenant oui force décision dans le
centre ça j'aime bien
si on te demande est en ce moment qu'ils
allaient gagner le match en totale
ce serait encore difficile à dire parce
qu'également ce que personne n'arrive à
prendre l'initiative dans le match et
garder l'initiative
on a fini la moitié des parties de trois
minutes
il reste 28 minutes et demie sur sur une
heure donc ils ont joué quatre 4 parties
de 3 et 1 et reste trois ou quatre
encore je suis curieux de voir si oui
seuil et de commandes et langil parti le
plus possible comme s'ils jouent le rôle
est pour qu'il n'y ait pas trop de
partis parce que jusqu'à maintenant il
ne vendons toujours tout de suite quand
tu penses que c'est fini oui pour avoir
comme juste parties de blitz kiel où il
est oui se trouve peut-être plus
favorisés que angolais mais il est aussi
vraiment sa stratégie dans cette partie
c'est fear ou jackie qui essaient
d'allumer un feu et le sac et fille il a
sacrifié le pion des quatre pour pour
faire des menaces actif il vous est
peut-être joué g4 pour pour attraper le
cavalier h5 mais ne pouvait pas cette
partie très intéressante puisque c'est
l'énorme de pions detroit les blancs
sont simplement mieux
les scènes garder sociaux veulent manger
4 1
alors maintenant 9,4 s'il aurait pu
échanger sur ces 3 il aurait était sûr
de garder le pion mais il ya eu quelque
chose qui n'allait pas et là du besoin
du tempo et maintenant il a perdu le
pion mais ça reste compliqué puisque les
blancs jouer à quatre le roi blanc n'est
pas parfait non plus à la fin du camp
des six hommes font vraiment de fonction
on pourrait échanger mètres la tour sur
l'a5 ici ou pas possible nous mais le
retour 5 preuve toi oui c'est
intéressant c'est un premier oui oui oui
et après tout cette recette peut être
forcée mais puis tour à st galler fort
ouais donc avait toujours raison c'est
une position difficile pour les noirs
qui arrive maintenant mais je crois que
j'aurais dû essayer de l'option d'être
impossible voilà diam hcc howe
lachance terme à quatre voies bonne
défense way to rav4 ici oui le roi doit
bouger les foules assistant
oui tour g4 ici peut-être parce qu'il ya
matière g8
non leur cible à vii ok c'est bien mais
qu'est ce qu'il va faire pour défendre
le plan des 4 c'est difficile de faire
il va pas le faire las en l'air il
avance le plonger ses biens au moins ça
limite le fou j'ai cette même s'il ne
peut pas jouer g6 et c'est bien d'avoir
ces pions là rien de plus vrai
du coup on fera quelques quelques cases
noires là avec ses pions elle pourrait
même jouer 5 6 mélie storengy cette
recette vous prenez 4
très peu de temps pour les lois ou faux
c'est pas bien pour le roi ça non plus
jouer tour recette d'un nom il joue pas
tout réussissait
il va juste prendre à six essais c'est
trop straumann visite aux belles parties
de fil rouge à bellemare dit ok après
d'état 2e quatre cavalières trois
cahiers c3 qui ne m'impressionnait pas
on va voir autre chose ici dit oui je
crois que c'est bien que les chances
huawei 7 et ans était largement temps
quoi on peut jouer eux cinq ici chacun
car oui j'ai 400 reprendre dont il
reprend simplement
mais là ce pion est complètement mort
sur cinq c'est pas vrai on peut pas
jouer comme ça les blancs auraient même
pu prendre avec le fou comme ça il n'y a
pas eu de médaille
si ce recul et puis cavaillé à 3 et 6
mois mais maintenant jusqu'à valait
d'être ok mais dans la lignée que tu
disais ok sk ii aussi connu un autre
mois selon moi c'est juste
incompréhensible comme il donne ses
pions et 5
je suis d'accord russie mais ne devait
pas commencer par comme les supports
autour c'est pour voir tour c'est
pourquoi pas f4 moi je jouerai à 4 ici
très vite et f4 sa mort
ben ouais une seule pause j'allais dire
c'est notre première position où on peut
jouer g4 et c'est pas mauvais donc
maintenant sa voix ils ont réussi à
battre ses manches pour les blancs mais
c'est un oui ouais je sais pas si c'est
assez pour gagner parce qu'il ya des
problèmes avec la position blanche mais
mais peut-être je pensais que les noirs
allaient simplement échanger lecavalier
sur ces deux prendre colo déjouer j'ai
cinq cavaliers g6 c'est ce qui est
important c'est que les noirs n'arrive
pas immobiliser les doublons sur les
cases blanches
un jour ils vont se mettre en marche
aucun cas par exemple dans ce cas on
peut dire que c'est trop ok on ce cas
peut-être le noir pourrait penser à
jouer à 5 et que par là oui mais ici de
nains peuvent prendre et h4 comment
sortir marron à cause de cavaillé g5 f4
quatre cadres go wi fi roja pourquoi tu
lui as donné ce pion pourquoi pourquoi
es3 et es6 es7 avec monde technique le
plan doivent qu'à mieux personnellement
que le viol que les bleus montent avions
de plus mais aussi la structure voire et
comme promis voilà fichu la halle elle
est maintenant le fou est complètement
corrects je trouve que c'est une bonne
partie de wii ware est mais aussi fil
rouge à le lien peut donner
oui mais ce n'est jamais évident que tu
réalises est une tâche de manière
tellement précises ok ce que te trouver
les charges 4g 5 puis tour hk à cet
effort au csis
alors à 3 satiné ou pas oui peut-être
plus que ça ne l'est pas donc sur
cavaliers detroit il veut répondre avec
faut prendre ces 6 il paraît que des
fois je comprends bien voilà
bon je pense pas qu'il ya deux contres
jeu pour furent russia il abandonne
hockey
les deux suspects toujours abandonné un
set au aa
notre premier petrov c'est ça ouverture
principal quand je les parties et
l'homme
oui oui mais sûrement les caisses quand
je vous cavaillé des 4 j'en ai vu
évidemment plein de partie dans cette
ouverture mais je ne vais pas compris
alors ça n'aide pas à grand chose avec
le piote un sicilien cible si on arrive
je vais être g4 g5 en contre pour les
noirs ce n'est pas si facile d'ouvrir
des pronos entre à oui peut-être assez
spécial coup quelque chose oui n'a
normalement oui c'est ça justement
wouah il peut ça revient juste à fou de
douleur reposer n'est ce pas donc si
c'est une partie longue ce serait
parfait pour un nul et pas vraiment
parce que les bleus ont pénétré le
septième rangée mai mais ils ont ils
menti développement les noirs peuvent
jouer autour des 8 je pense à un
prochain au prochain coup on va voir
parce que tourner cette tour bien j'ai
deux tours 8 3 1
il va perdre là je pense un tueur un ça
marche pas parce qu'à la fin il y aurait
trop vite et chaque heure 3 olalalala je
crois qu'il aurait pu prendre mais c est
à cause de cette ligne non c'est un
passif auquel on va voir très je dois
alors oui le g3 où tour à cette
jetteront g3 alors toujours eu un petit
tour b 8 échecs weitz est fou détroit
n'importe quoi tu as raison je vois là
ok voyons la partie tour des 5 parce que
tu as eu raison si on arrive à changer
nos tours 17
c'est avec les photos posées si c'est
incroyable ce fou détroit
je crois qu'ici les noirs doivent juste
garder la position ne pas toucher les
piaules à épeler peut-être si les bleus
jouent à saint héand jours à 6 pour ne
pas permettre les blondes de le faire
parce que le simple on serait de 4,5 est
rentré quelques pas ouais donc on peut
en ce serait dangereux de perdre la
caisse et 6 oui jusqu'où dangereux
disons maintenant il arrive déjà à
changer les taux il peut même si je vais
tourner puisque soit 17 il ya un an ça
ne marche pas sur 17 fois cécile 1.4 et
regagne notre pions
ça se complique maintenant oui peut-être
faute n est pas tellement bien
quatre des sept
et puis ici il faut 4 7 m ce soir c'est
sa fougue et cette tournée cette fois
des sols ça continue encore
pourquoi pas b6 françois demande c'est
parce que quand le fou blanc arrive sur
ses six pour défendre à jamais le pian
17 alors c'est très difficile pour les
noirs de toujours défendre la case des
8es les blancs en appui sur ie8 peuvent
mettre le tour là les noirs ne peuvent
jamais d'échangés et les noirs arrivent
dans des situations ils ne peuvent pas
du tout bougé le roi blanc peut avancer
jusqu'à ses quatre à six à sept petits
trucs comme ça
j'ai vu deux des tas de finale a décidé
comme ça par un parent pions comme ça
maintenant s'est tassé de fieux pour le
mois beaucoup de casse d'entrée pour le
bios planches et tour ici c'est aussi
très fort il ya un petit problème avec
la coordination du roi qui se fait
presque mater là
[Musique]
déjà le mois d'août très souvent
lentement bien sûr mais oui y défend
très bien il ya eu plusieurs positions
où j'ai pensé oh c'est difficile et il
s'en est sorti pas mal
l'impression 3 à 5
sassus encore regardé les tours pas
fonctionné ça doit être une dune je
pense
ok par contre le fou noir il ne reste
comme ça
si le référé changer tous les droits
sais c'est nul à reims 3 1
comme annoncé le retour avec le voir
facile c'est facile objectivement mais
quand on a deux secondes facile de faire
un peu le fil oui ok combien de partis
le reste il en 3 1
il ya huit minutes donc probablement
encore une partie après celle ci ouais
je trouve que loyers a très bien défendu
est ce qu'on peut avoir eu 5 le nouveau
ici ça c'est pour redonner le pire non
pas cette fois la sacema membres parce
qu' ils arrivent sur une position que je
joue beaucoup avec les blanches hockey
et probablement aussi contre l'érosion
est aussi con tre fiori jaoui donc ces
partis mais c'était toujours comme sa
prison de st et sinon après de reprendre
avec le cavalier jeu pour découvrir le
seigle et cavani c4 est un des six est
réussi ouais style belle position pour
les blancs ça oui j'ai gagné aucune
partie comme ça
ok il joue d'une autre si d'ici avec
tours 1 donc ça va être une position un
peu plus est et indienne classique ça
oui et maintenant le cavalier
oui parce que normalement dans sa
structure et dans cette voie comme
lecavalier
trois des quatre pieds rouges à et il a
quitté le clavier prend un moment il
était debout dans la salle
ils criaient à l'ordinaire à
l'ordinateur mais qu'est ce que tu fais
qu'est ce que tu fais comme si c'est
l'ordinateur qui avait joué le coup pour
lui oui les fichiers les fâchés et huayi
rien c'est juste normal sur wii il
continue à réfléchir comme si la partie
allait continuer vers oujda a l'air de
crier pour un arbitre tu sais c'est que
quand quelque chose bizarre se passer
c'est très rare dans un tournoi mais
quand quelque chose se passe qu'il ya
mais il est où l'arbitré ouais il
cherche un arbitre il est parti un
pierrot jahier parti et équité oui
arrêter de calculer enfin non il
recommence petite pause de seconde
plusieurs pensent l'ouverture de la
prochaine
et je pense que je pense qu'ils sont sur
le même appel donc je pense que oui peut
voir que fit roja est parti je pense je
suis pas sûre de sa voix c'est une bonne
question mérite je pense que les joueurs
s'entrevoit donc il sait que l'autre et
est parti en rage mais et encore il
était là à calculer quelque chose s'il
est ouvert six toujours seulement un
écran va minimiser
ah oui tu aurais juste et chic et même
si tu es dans l'appel pourquoi tu
regardes ray le visage de l'autre tout
le temps en particulier fille roujas il
regard sur le visage de wailly va rien y
trouver
donc ça vaut pas l'écran il réfléchit
encore à ses 5 pourquoi pas c'est
marrant parce que j'avais déjà plus
qu'une minute pour réfléchir sur se
reposer sur wii et s'endort là
maintenant c'est quoi penses-tu wailly à
quoi penses tu là à trouver autre chose
ouah c'est pas mal ce qu'ils arrêtent
avance les attaques sur les droits
s'affaiblit un peu changé ce deux pièces
je pense que je vais y arriver à mon
tournoi de fisher indom pas de problème
technique jusqu'ici peut-être encore 40
50 minutes de match et moi j'ai soixante
dix minutes avant mon tournoi c'est
super oui je suis d'accord avec jay-z
web c'est le contraste entre ces deux
tempéraments c'est intéressant parce que
grand chose tu pense que ce sera nul oui
c'est le tour e 1
et sinon f4 ici peut-être oui le 5 ou 6
et de continuer je pense moi mesdames e3
donc le sais parce que spirent f5 comme
c'est comme une mini faiblesse je peux
être csp rétro mais par contre est ce
que tu fais dans le 3g 3 je suppose je
veux je veux jouer tour un plus tard
mais mais j'attends pour le moment et si
les noirs jouent tous réussissent trop
vite je veux essayer de prendre le pian
sur à 5
bien sûr mais surtout m chez toi je veux
continuer avec ta meuf de voix puis oui
dit qu'est ce que tu fais tu
m'impressionnes pas je reste ici journée
à annuler des centaines de parties comme
ça à mon cher à 3 4 5
ok peut-être mais ce serait le rêve de
le mettre sur sur la longue diagonale et
puis peut-être utilisé la faible assure
quatre pour cacher c'est sur cinq
mais pour le moment tu as raison il
attend sur g4 comme ça le tour libéré
huawei latour libéré c'est bien un
pompon
et puis retourner tranquille sur z15
aussi roi dame des cinq cet effort c'est
une bonne position pour la dame et puis
ça crée des menaces c'est toujours la
même histoire dense dans ce système de
l'albatros wallons restent avec leurs
quatre pions et le très très bien non il
un peu plus exposés donc est ce qu'il ya
une raison pour laquelle il peut pas
prendre le pion f5 irréfléchie assez
longtemps et c'est curieux à 9,1
j'ai toujours bien acheté en prise par
exemple si tu prends un homme seul
je reprends airways pas évident comme tu
continues à oui juste aller en finale
des - ouais ouais ok je comprends donc
ils avancent et quatre sites
intéressants tout être le jouet mort des
trois accords maintenant il va attaquer
le pian c7 avec tmc 8 et peut même jouer
b5 ici peut-être mais ça pourrait être
très très fort a comme ça intéressant
parce que un c'est b 4 c 5 c'est l'idée
et voilà b5 éventuellement oro bien il
avait prévu sa dame revient pour
défendre ses deux difficiles pour broyer
il va devoir prouver ses talents de
défense et c'est avec lui deux secondes
ouais ouais
probablement comme g21 cherche un chèque
perpétuelle ça c'est fort 4ème c3 ici
peut-être c'est en quoi ce serait ne le
pense pas parce que tu n'arrives pas un
final de pions mais maintenant on le
voit h5
non non non 1,5 la soirée par h4 je ne
comprends pas bien joué
qu'est ce qu'il fait mais à l'air mais à
l'ère des arbres comme ça aussi un je
croyais que c'était un an de toute façon
les noms des 4 et 5 8 cinq mois s'est
jamais possible de tout bloquer sur
l'ale sur le droit et ses débuts avant
que le roi soit la g5 lui même avant que
les blancs et le coup j'ai 4 mais
peut-être même là quand on joue g5 les
jeux blancs sg 4 quelque chose au les
trois minutes des parties de trois
mythes sont finies donc avantage de deux
points en entrant en boulettes pour oui
ça peut être pas suffi je crois que dans
la dernière juste après les changes
comme g5 l'oréal avons les changent
d'âne juste juste après le chanteur
hockey exactement l'avait croix sur ses
sept
j'ai cinq ans les blancs jouent
peut-être au g4 pris sur les quatre axes
un quai puis ag 3ware c'est ça parce que
les noirs et leurs sacrément jeu régis
quatre ports fermés tôt 6 les bleues ne
réagissent pas
ok les gars on prend un petit peu une
petite pause puis on revient pour les
boulettes dans je suis pas trois minutes
ou quatre minutes quelque chose comme ça
[Musique]
ça recommence
les boulettes sont partis trente minutes
de temps pour qu'elle et rza montrent un
come back a pas trois de nouveau or dans
les poses leur écrire ça c'est un
nouveau coup et a trouvé quelque chose
et a trouvé quelque chose pendant la
pause
non je n'ai jamais vu ça non pire j'ai
réfléchi c'est quoi comme avait quatre
c'est la différence
la même position 4 c'est un problème en
c2 ok donc pour le moment il a réussi à
piquer un pion oui mais si c'était parce
qu'ils vont être tués
oui mais qu'est ce qu'il va faire pour
pour le fou de rouille pas le problème
pour offrir ou pas de problème moi ça
avance vite maintenant j'ai du mal à
même voir les coûts il aurait pu prendre
sur ces deux je pense non c'était pas
l'idée oui il aurait du sens d'un b777
non tu vas gagner ce fait naître cette
finale je pense m'en fous j'ai quatre
c'est déjà une répétition d'un f3 t'as
raison euros tu as raison mais l'or
[Musique]
de même quand même 1 et peut lancer sur
h57 c'est pas un problème ça va faire un
impact là
oh
ben pas
[Musique]
quote oui moi je donne un peu plus de
place un espace aux le cas c'était bien
eu cinq moins bien toi f4 et les noirs
sont tout à fait correctes
ces deux c2 donc va activer pas mal au
real et je vais tout de suite
[Musique]
joli joli c'est 5
non c'est pas possible le four doit être
gardée à eau
ça va mal pour voyez cette boulette à
tour des cinq sinon sinon c'était une
reprise de cette finale qu'on a déjà vu
aux îles cour a très bien et ne laisse
pas passer c'est comme une thèmes de
tours est fou contre tours
ce truc là toujours pas pas de sortie
désolé moi mais il semble connaître
assez bien la défense de why is et c'est
incroyable c'est vraiment vraiment bien
oh il y avait tout à 5 il devait ne
pouvait pas aller sur quatre oh la la
c'est que parfois votre bien ouais ça
devient difficile à un moment et puis et
puis c'est une machine un certain moment
on va ou rester au centre sava aussi ou
pas c'est plus simple si tu en as un f
ou bien
à deux c'est un mécanisme rien ne peut
arriver
ouais c'est même pas besoin de réfléchir
il est passé de 3 secondes à 10 secondes
je pense pas qu'il va perdre cette
partie là whaou
c'est être un peu frustrant pour fil
rouge la avait gagné 3 prend trois pions
et puis ne pas pouvoir convertir au il a
perdu ses trois et a perdu ses 3300 de
corte et maintenant le pétrole fly se
sont à l'aise il a sorti les vraies
armes là avec le pétrole ça c'est pour
annuler à 100%
une dizaine de parties de suite c'est
marrant qu'il joue n'importe quoi tout
principe deux heures de n'importe quoi
puis en boulette c'est otis et avec ça
on peut annuler tu sais on souffre un
petit peu mais ça va ah oui excusez moi
ici c'était f4 la dernière fois pour
éviter même cinq obstacles blier ta
préparation fil rouge à allô c'est moi
un effort il avait complètement raté ça
mais l'idée avant c'était qu'on pouvait
pas moins
adama l'air faible mais maintenant
trouver cette menace tourbe et 8 pas ton
pour tour pour trouver six comme tu
voulais non finis au juste un point
devant le maître de blade est introduit
et il abandonne tout de suite il
pourrait aussi laisser passer le
transport ouais donc on voit là que ce
n'est pas exactement sa stratégie mais
dernière partie c'était le 4 ici et a
pris sur des quatre silva pas de
cavalier g4 c'est le changement à il
veut vraiment jouer cavalier 4 mais oui
s'attend à ça c'est plus forts
consommateurs punk ou c3 oui ça a l'air
bien mais bécotte bonne position
t'embête presque doit défendre
qu'est ce qui peut faire f4 f5 ça a
l'air fort si les noirs ne peuvent pas
mais sauce bouge et ça aussi c'est bien
mais je ne vois pas comment jeudi on se
trouve
[Musique]
oh lecavalier n'a nulle part où aller
1-5 donné la qualité ici sinon le 5 ça
va trop fort oui et à trouver un co et
sur dame g7
il faut que cette caisse qui va faire là
n'a rien trouvé du tout ouais ouais
je suis d'accord avec toi ça va être ça
va être la première partie gagnée en
boulettes par oui et pour lui aussi ça
c'est très important et doit et il doit
se prouver qui peut gagner des parties
en volley entre fille roja sinon c'est
juste c'est juste marqué du temps à
essayer de survivre pendant que l'autre
gagne il essaie de faire quelques nuls
ça c'est pas une bonne attitude un tour
c'est un an
pourquoi pas tour c'est un rêve où jouer
il voulait un tour c'est pas si facile
que ça 1co huawei ça c'est bien ça c'est
bien là une autre la classe c'était au
point de tourner
voilà un tarif 1 e les jetons à non
c'est vrai ça fait mal payés il va se
demander s'il peut même gagner des
parties en boulettes après ça mais là
toujours davantage s'il ne marche pas
dans une fourchette
voilà qu'est ce qu'il fait là je crois
pas qu'il doit essayer de gagner même
pas essayé parce qu'il n'y a aucun plan
juste marcher dans une fourchette
une fois sur dix il n'y a rien que je
peux passer à droite tu attends
simplement
mais il peut jouer ça pour l'éternité
finale mais il répète simplement pour
faire un nul
ok ça c'est vraiment décevant pour oui
je pense assez ça c'est dur à supporter
oui continue on apprend des choses on
apprend que les noirs ne menace pas
vraiment des cinq dans cette position là
qu'est ce qu'il a à faire maintenant je
n'ai jamais vu ça
lorsqu'on 28 oui avant du match a dit je
n'ai aucune confiance dans ce match
c'est évident que en blitz il est plus
fort que moi un des gens il avait 19
même avant le match qui n'avait aucune
chance donc du tout mais il a gagné la
portion plus de cinq minutes et de trois
minutes par un point chacun
oui si impressionné la défense ans toman
le portier roi fit super ça c'est une
bien meilleure qu'à ce que g8 je pense
ici mais comme elias juste un coup de
foudre cases blanches droit indien
c'est bien de mettre en cause hors
achats
il veut jouer h5
et c'est pareil le pion f dû plonger
maçons il doit aussi défendre ce pion
toujours mais maintenant je n'ai aucune
idée comment les gens peuvent améliorer
la position de noir remettre le rhône
cet essai supersoluce être un jour au le
pian h5 est en péril un peu mais tous
les gens blancs sont sur les causes
planche s'il veut gagner j'ai saisi va
jouer pour gagner ce piège
oh le pauvre ok donc maintenant on
s'attend à une défense merveilleuse de
fil rouge à cette partie oui mais quid
si c'est juste une faiblesse de plus la
sueur à 4 contre 5
qu'est ce qui peut faire maintenant
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire construire et
c'est trop solide on a quatre peut être
joué aussi maintenant je souhaite aussi
améliorer toutes les pièces jusqu'au
maximum
oui mais s'ils s'y joue à quatre avec le
fou sur 17 éventuellement quelque chose
alors la tour blanche ne peut jamais
quitté la colonne a sinon les noirs
jouent tour à 5o a gagné en temps
wassa cet effort c'est sa première
victoire de boulettes
il récupère son avantage de deux points
il reste deux certainement
l'impressionnant 13 minutes encore cinq
ou six parties deux points d'avance ici
[Musique]
ouais donc ici si jouer eux 4 et
cavaliers des deux cavaliers c4 ce
serait le genre de position dont tu
parlais il ya aussi une position pas mal
du jouet c4 et les ses deux pions de
n'est ce pas ce serait aussi jouable oui
mais je préfère comme ça le covan et ans
écopent chacun a ses six semaines donc
il n'ya pas de 15,1 des six ans ou plus
ou moins car il n'y a pas d'idée sauf
s'il ya ce au rouge a tu dois voir par
là parce que si tu te bats là ça peut
être la dernière
cavaillé c6 ça c'est le grand fou au fur
jacques crie et hurle
on peut échanger sur l'a6 et jouer eux 5
s'il veut simplifier après pas de
problème tactique surtout ruidiaz
toujours à quatre et ça va ok il met le
pian sur l'a6 le pion est faible pour
ses reins ou tour e set simplement
dessus de maintiennent s'était pas
vraiment nécessaire c'est mieux avec la
tour sur recettes que sur 3 non oui il
va perdre la partie mama les dames est
faible mais non il ya trop voulu h5
peut-être d'un projet trop en premier
aux quais qui a fait retour 3 deuxième
fois ils peuvent entrer en jeu
si seulement il a des passants pion à
six cavaliers ac se serait ce serait
gagnant
cavalia 6 se serait sauvé quatre
ailleurs il reste combien sur la pomme
dimanche encore 10 minutes qui a tracé
par tea party
ok défense impossible ici à tourbes est
un droit et abandonne hockey ou c'est
[Musique]
juste un point ça fait un moment qu'on a
pas vu deux des quatre hockey grand but
catalan
tout à coup ce sont mes sauts verture
trois jours sans mais ouverture oui oui
j'allais dire je sais que tu connais ça
parce que en prod chassery que je vient
d'observer une belle partie que tu as
joué ici en en finale de fou opposée ce
succès c'est un masque ici n'est ce pas
oui j'ai un peu bizarre tout ça
ces trucs à vannes le 4 mai
oui alors c'était important d'échanger
lecavalier axis toujours utile d'avoir
peur de forme et astrid francis
maintenant inconnu ce salaire de gagner
l'avion ah oui oui oui comme ça même
comme ça c'est pas bien haut mais un
pion ça va c'est c'est toujours possible
de défendre on a vu plus souvent une
défense que quelqu'un gains dans ses
positions avec un pion et que peu de
partis ou quelqu'un converti un pion
mais un bon lot
oui je voulais dire comme lui j'aime
bien jouer avec lui maintenant une
chance pour moi il y avait toujours des
choses pour défendre à c'est l'histoire
de ce match
il se fait des faiblesses pour créer des
faiblesses pour échanger des pions 4
roger un projet ça va maintenant les
blancs doivent répéter je pense en un il
ya tours 7
après tours à 6 échecs du tueur cette
eau eau
qu'est ce qui se passe là j'en sais rien
ça serait de défendre un seul mois
jusqu'à ce qu'on me prouve le contraire
je vais toujours attendre nul ça doit
être le match avec le plus grand nombre
de nuls je pense parmi tous ses matches
en sus il y en a eu des matches avec
deux nuls parmi 20 parties dansées
speech à junior mais mellal les partis
qui ont été défendus c'est incroyable ah
ah ah les résas ne peux pas le croire il
est comme kwame quoi c'est n'importe
quoi
arrête d'annuler arrête défendre tu fais
chier avec ses défenses hurle c'était
des paragraphes qu'il a dit là whaou
encore 5 minutes
avantage d'un point pour oui tu sais ce
qui se passe si c'est un match égal
georg marti non non ça change et ils
font un mini-match de quatre parties de
boules est parce que j'en ai commenté
une autre match en anglais et ça finit
comme ça avec un mini-match de boulettes
et celui qui avait gagné la partie
paulette par 2,3 points
il a perdu le mini match 3-0 après avoir
récupéré trois points en boulettes qu'il
avait perdu en blitz
puis il est allé dans le tie break et
l'autre lui a battu 3-0 soudain ok
qu'est ce qui se passe là parce que je
pense que match égal c'est vraiment ça
entre dans la possibilité ici
les changer c'est encore une partie 2 à
3 je devine oui je suis pas regardez
bien le gouverneur mais oui c'était à 4
à 3
[Musique]
edf 4 je suppose
structure blanche et sans faiblesse la
structure blanche noire faible ouais
juste un peu cette case de f3 mais c'est
pas grave hein sera quatrième année à 3
je suis comme un de ces quatre ouais
ouais ouais c'est comme ça l'est ainsi
que tu te sortir un bon rythme et je
viens tension mais oui il a vu ses biens
est visée g5 depuis longtemps
comme un des quatre tours tellement
solide et c6 c'est celui des fins non
qu'est ce que tu vas créer maintenant
firoud qui est ce que tu as écrit il n'a
pas crié il est concentré mais ça c'est
pas très bien pour pour son roi échec
prendre sur l'a7 au nom on rêve d'un
premier hall à cette partie est intense
rashard lewis et 6 aussi aie aie aie
ok on sait pas encore ce qui va se
produire ici sur damas quatre il ya dame
ces cinq banques baffe pas foot 17
peut-être pour mission entre en finale
avec un pion de plus c'est rater un
on peut plus gagner c'est bien de plus
deux pions de plus parce qu'il ya ni
adam sur l'a6 au lieu de la bonne case 1
aurait pu arriver si c'était une erreur
gravissime
oh oh le contre avec un tour à quatre
tours à quatre génies on va voir une
partie gagnée
incroyable une partie gagnée au feu
rouge a été en danger maintenant il
reste une partie non il a perdu le match
il a perdu le match si la dernière
partie ya six ans et toujours en est au
courant et ne n'abandonne pas après
c'est pas juste une blague aux premières
émotions de wailly dans tout le match y
rigole qu'il a joué trois sets
[Musique]
ouais parce qu'il sait pas l'horloge et
ali rezaï
il est presque pas à son ordinateur
comment est-ce qu'il ya plus qu'une
minute et ils jouent comme comme ça
comme ça comme alors ailleurs
coordinateur
il a peu à peu il peut à peine atteindre
l'ordinateur il ya plus qu'une minute
encore mais c'est quoi ça non c'est pas
possible tant il est comme il est comme
ça j'ai jamais vu cette technique et
sont en avance toujours avance avance
avance chaque coup qui fait il a plus de
temps que que qu'avant mais c'est quoi
ça comment il le fait il n'est même pas
son ordi c'est le lien cérébrale déjà où
quelque chose on voyait lui défonce le
roi aïe aïe aïe brutale brutale
oh la la c'est fou ça
waouh il est fâché voilà lui il était au
courant du temps je pense que c'est pour
ça qu'il a joué la dernière partie comme
ça parce qu'ils savaient que qu'il ne
pouvait plus et probablement et
maintenant wailly à l'air d'attendre la
prochaine partie comme moi ok alors
bravo à tous les deux c'est est épatant
qu'en match
au nom même même les petrov n'était pas
si mal
c'est lé à trois stèles et à trois que
je ne supportais pas né à troyes dans
les quatre dans l'ouverture des quatre
jeux vous j'aime bien c'est pas trop
quoi la petrov 3e set waza c'était une
nouveauté nouveauté importante voie
voilà donc ben on n'a pas beaucoup plus
à vous dire avant de vous quitter parce
que moi j'ai un tournoi de fisher random
à jouer mais on pourrait parler une
seconde de la finale et qu'est-ce qu'on
attend la guerre qu il y avait deux
iraniens sur quatre dans les dents les
demi-finales et maintenant c'est la
chine contre les états unis qui me
benoît varin
et qui est ce que tu favorise dans dans
la finale oui
[Musique]
ouais si tu bats le premier c'est toi le
nouveau premier mais parce que c'était
assez impressionnant
je dis moi pour quelqu'un qui qui qui
disait lui-même n'y avait pas vraiment
de chance qui jouait pas bien ou au
blitz et on sait que avec la connexion
et joue pas beaucoup de boulettes
c'était c'était impressionnant mais mais
aussi c'est mike soudou été favorisée
contre chiant et chiant l'a fait très
bien
ouais il a gagné par 4 points c'était
c'était assez définitif mais aussi là et
je pense que chiant aussi il n'est pas
connu pour être un buteur mais il a
montré sa classe
dans toutes ces tout ses matchs
jusqu'ici alors je pense que il je pense
qu'il tiendra avec avec oui
le match sera assez serré où on dira 50
4% ce pour un ou pour l'autre
j'imagine que tu as raison en tout cas
ça serait la date de la finale n'est pas
encore connue je sais c'est ainsi
l'information plus importante que qui on
croit va gagner ou n'importe quoi c'est
tout ce que vous avez besoin c'est
l'heure pour y arriver le voir mais mais
c'est pas encore décidé ça dépend des
tournois des joueurs un peu mais ce sera
bien plus ce sera dans les premiers 10
jours doubt ça c'est que je sais quelque
part entre le 3 et le 11 quelque chose
comme ça et puis oui si vous voulez un
interview vous pouvez passer à la chaîne
principale en anglais vont est bon c'est
intéressant il interrogé en anglais sur
le match donc voilà nous on où on se
parle je pense work profitant de la
chaleur grèce pour voir l'interview et
un wiki si les fichiers random vous
intéresse je retourne en 20 minutes pour
rejouer du fisher un homme sur ma chaîne
10 pro x à tout à l'heure légale
[Musique]